was erwartet uns denn heute im Bundestag
ja heute morgen meine Damen und Herren
beschäftigt sich der Bundestag gleich
mit dem sogenannten doppelwumms so hat
der Bundeskanzler ja den 200 Milliarden
Euro Schirm zu Bekämpfung der
Energiekrise genannt und der wird heute
in erster Lesung quasi
gesetzgebungstechnisch auf den Weg
gebracht hier durch die Parlamentarier
es war ja schon überraschend dass die
gasumlage zwei Tage vor in Kraft treten
dann kassiert wurde oder wie der
Wirtschaftsminister Harbig gesagt hat in
die Annalen der Geschichte eingegangen
ist statt eine Belastung der
Gasverbraucher hat der Bundeskanzler am
gleichen Tag verkündet es gäbe ein 200
Milliarden Paket mit einer
gaspreisbremse also einer Entlastung für
die Verbraucher und in diesem Paket
enthalten ist dann auch noch die Rettung
der gasimporteure die ja in schwere Not
geraten sind und eine
Zwischenfinanzierung soll dort enthalten
sein für die strompreisbremse die ja
auch noch nicht beschlossen worden ist
ja alles dieses
wenn man in Form bringen und das tut man
mit dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der zum
Glück noch übrig geblieben war aus
corona-zeiten der soll jetzt ermächtigt
werden dieses Jahr 200 Milliarden Euro
noch aufzunehmen und in dieses Gesetz
muss dann auch noch rein wie dieses Geld
ausgegeben werden soll das ist ja noch
nicht so ganz klar es gab eine
Kommission die sehr schnell arbeiten
musste einen Zwischenbericht vorgelegt
hat 96 Milliarden hat man da
ausgerechnet darauf kommen wir gleich
nämlich im Gespräch mit meinen Gästen
die ich heute morgen ganz herzlich
begrüße Julia Verlinden die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der bündnisgrün ist da nicht nur in Bonn
wird heute gearbeitet auch nach wie vor
hier morgens in Berlin natürlich guten
Morgen und Andreas Jung der Energie- und
klimapolitische Sprecher der
cdu/csu-fraktion und bekanntlich
stellvertretender Parteivorsitzender der
Christdemokraten
Frau Verlinden ich fahre gleich mal mit
der Tür ins Haus 200 Milliarden das ist
sehr sehr viel Geld aber reicht das denn
überhaupt wir gucken uns das mal an die
Rettung der energiebetreiber der der
gasimporteure kostet Milliarden das
Paket was viele sagen ist noch nicht so
ausgegoren was da vorgelegt wurde 96
Milliarden da fehlt noch eine Komponente
für den Mittelstand sagen viele da fehlt
vor allen Dingen für Öl und Pellet
Kunden etwas also das könnte auch noch
mehr werden und dann gibt es zum
Beispiel den Fraktionschef der SPD Herr
Mütze nicht der gesagt hat also einen
Monat in der Start im Dezember übernimmt
ist zu wenig ich könnte mir dann zweiten
Monat vorstellen ja reicht das denn aus
wenn das ganze geht bis zum Jahr 2024
und die Hoffnung dass die Gaspreise dann
deutlich wieder niedriger sein werden
woher nehmen sie die
also erstmal bin ich sehr dankbar dafür
dass die Regierung diese 200 Milliarden
jetzt zur Verfügung stellt weil wir
brauchen sie dringend für die Entlastung
und um gut durch diesen Winter zu kommen
sie haben recht es sind viele unbekannte
noch im Spiel auch dahingehend wie
entwickeln sich die Energiepreise auch
weiter in den nächsten Monaten aber wir
können jetzt klar sagen alle können sich
dann wenn das Ergebnis der Kommission so
umgesetzt wird auch tatsächlich auf
einen gedeckelten Gaspreis verlassen für
die nächsten Monate bis also mindestens
bis März 24 und ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiges Signal im übrigen sind
alle gaskundinnen und Kunden davon
betroffen das heißt alle werden
entlastet auch der Mittelstand das heißt
alle profitieren sowohl von der
Einmalzahlung im Dezember als auch von
der dem gaspreisdeckel dann ab nächstem
Jahr insofern wird es mit Sicherheit den
ein oder anderen Härtefall geben auch
aber auch hierfür hat die Kommission
vorgeschlagen ein zusätzlichen hilfsfon
auf den Weg zu bringen und auszubauen ja
alle werden entlastet der Mittelstand
sagt jetzt schon das werden wir nicht
überleben wenn eine Zahlung im Dezember
kommt und die nächste dann im März oder
April durch den Deckel Herr Jungen die
Opposition kritisiert das ja unter
anderem auch und sagt es ist alles nicht
zielgenau das würde ja bedeuten auch
sagt die Opposition wir brauchen
eigentlich tatsächlich mehr Geld wo
wollen sie das her nehmen es ist gar
nicht klar ob wir mehr Geld brauchen
oder ob man auch so viel Geld braucht
weil die 200 Milliarden die haben sich
ja nicht aus irgendeiner seriösen
Rechnung ergeben mit dem man
festgestellt hätte wieviel brauchen wir
für die gaspreisbremse wie viel brauche
für die Unterstützung der Bürger wie
viel brauchen wir für den Mittelstand
sondern ist eine Hausnummer die einfach
in den Raum gestellt wurden um die
rhetorische Figur des doppelwurms
irgendwie zu unterlegen das ist die
Reihenfolge die wir kritisieren es geht
hier um viel Geld insgesamt geht der
Bundesfinanzminister mit 500 Milliarden
Euro Schulden in den Bundestag in diesem
Jahr und das sollte man nicht
leichtfertig tun es ist klar in dieser
Situation muss der Start stark reagieren
muss unterstützen und stützen aber dann
muss doch erstmal geklärt werden wie
viel brauchen wir wofür und das ist bis
zum heutigen Tag nicht getan worden wir
wissen bei der gaspreisbremse welche
Kosten die Kommission erwartet es gibt
noch keine Haltung der Bundesregierung
dazu bei den anderen Instrumenten haben
wir Lehrstellen die Reihenfolge ist
falsch und Christian Lindner muss
erklären wie das was er hier vorhat mit
den Vorgaben der Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes zu vereinbaren ist weil
die Schuldenbremse sieht ja vor jedes
Jahr muss die eingehalten werden das
hier ist aber die Aktion Hamsterbacke
dieses Jahr werden viele Schulden
aufgenommen und schon jetzt ist klar das
Geld soll in den nächsten Jahren
verauslagt werden apropos Schuldenbremse
also die muss in diesem Jahr noch einmal
abgestimmt werden weil der 200
Milliarden dazu kommen das ist
wahrscheinlich nur pro forma da braucht
man die Kanzler mehr hat oder sehen Sie
das Schwierigkeiten ich sehe da
überhaupt keine Schwierigkeiten denn
dafür ist ja dieser dieser Posten im
Haushalt vorgesehen und ich glaube dass
wir uns alle einig sind dass wir hier
wenn wir entlasten wollen wenn wir gut
durch diesen Winter kommen wollen wenn
wir die Menschen unterstützen wollen bei
diesen stark steigenden Energiepreisen
dann müssen wir jetzt Geld ausgeben aber
was natürlich auch wichtig ist ist wir
müssen auch überlegen wie können wir
langfristig uns absichern vor steigenden
fossilen Preisen und deswegen ist es
auch gut jeder Euro der investiert wird
in erneuerbare Energien in
Energieeffizienz der hilft uns
langfristig und ist eine Versicherung
vor steigenden Energiepreisen ja das ist
ja die Diskussion auch auf dem grünen
Parteitag heute Abend die Frage eben die
AKWs die FDP will keine Verlängerung ich
will eine Verlängerung die Grünen
natürlich nicht das ist die
Angebotsseite die Opposition kritisiert
das ja auch und sagt jetzt muss Angebot
her auch unter anderem damit der Preis
sinkt ja es geht nicht um ein Ausstieg
aus dem Ausstieg wir haben mit guten
Gründen den Ausstieg was der Kohle
verströmung beschlossen und den Ausstieg
aus der Kernenergie aber jetzt geht es
durch darum dass wir in dieser Krise
alle Kapazitäten nutzen um das was nach
wie vor droht auch nach Einschätzung der
Experten der Regierung nämlich ein
Notstand Blackouts dem entgegenzuwirken
das sagen ja die Übertragung die sagen
auch nicht
übertragungsnetzbetreibertragungsnetzbetreiber
kommen in ihrem Szenario zu dem Ergebnis
des unter bestimmten Annahmen Blackouts
drohen das ist die Einschätzung der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber im Stresstest
und deshalb haben die eine ganz klare
Empfehlung ausgesprochen sie formulieren
uns dort es trinkt der Rat in dieser
Krise alle Kapazitäten nutzen und wir
erleben dass die Regierung auf
Braunkohle setzt die soll bis zwei 24
laufen aber ein CO2-neutrales Kraftwerk
im Emsland soll Ende dieses Jahres
abgestellt werden es soll ein
ölkraftwerk um Emsland zu ersetzen
angeworfen werden des CO2-Ausstoß das
was das passt nichts ist der Plan der
Bundesregierung ist uns in diese Woche
in einer Antwort behauptet Gestaltung
versuchen
wie ist das mit dem AKW in Niedersachsen
das ist eines der modernsten überhaupt
1988 ans Netz gegangen hat 11 Milliarden
Kilowattstunden
94%ige Auslastung es ist weltweit eines
der best ausgelastesten und sichersten
Atomkraftwerke und die Grünen sagen das
brauchen wir nicht mehr wie wollen Sie
diese 11 Milliarden Kilowattstunden
ersetzen wir brauchen das Atomkraftwerk
Emsland deswegen nicht weil wir im
Norden sehr sehr viel Strom produzieren
aus Erneuerbaren in der Vergangenheit
hat das Atomkraftwerk an dem Standort im
Emsland immer wieder auch dafür gesorgt
dass Windstrom abgeregelt werden musste
weil dieses Atomkraftwerk die Netze
verstopft hat also macht es überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn dieses Atomkraftwerk
auch nur einen Tag länger laufen zu
lassen als Silvester das ist das was
verabredet worden ist man Aufstieg
damals übrigens mit Stimmen der CDU aber
im Norden wenn ich diesen Einwand machen
darf im Norden wird Braunkohle
angeworfen bis Ende zwei 24 im Norden
Luftlinie 150 km von dem Kernkraftwerk
Emsland setzen sie auf Braunkohle die
Regierung hat uns mitgeteilt man stehe
in Verhandlungen über einen Standort für
das schwimmte ölkraftwerk auch im Norden
das alles im Norden geht
im Norden gemacht werden
nicht durch schwimmende ölkraftwerke
ersetzt werden müssen es gab Angebote
von privaten Unternehmen die der
Bundesregierung gesagt haben wir haben
diese schwimmenden Kraftwerke die
Stellen könnten wir zur Verfügung
stellen die Bundesregierung hat gesagt
brauchen wir nicht und das ist jetzt
eine privatwirtschaftliche Entscheidung
ob die einen Antrag stellen dafür müssen
natürlich Genehmigung erteilt wenn etc
aber mir ist kein solcher Antrag bekannt
wir brauchen diese schwimmenden
ölkraftwerke im Norden nicht wir haben
dort ausreichend Energie die
Bundesregierung hat uns etwas anderes
mitgeteilt aber ist ja leicht
aufzuklären sie antworte Staatssekretär
jung auffällig ist natürlich dass wenn
man mal ins europäische Ausland guckt
dort längst gaspreisbremsen Strompreis
Bremsen verabschiedet wurde gerade bei
strompreisbremsen in Österreich zum
Beispiel zugig immer so ein bisschen auf
weil die deutsche Bundesregierung sagt
wir tun es da ganz schwer mit der
europäischen kompeten Komponente jetzt
will man das eben hier auch in diesen
Fonds reinpacken was ist da los eine
gaspreisbremse muss kommen das haben wir
es Union frühzeitig gefordert die
Kommission schlägt es jetzt vor in den
Beratung ist deutlich geworden es
braucht ein Vorlauf von mindestens vier
Monaten das unsere kernkritik hätte Olaf
Schulze es ja im Juli sein Satz gesagt
hat Julian never walk alone keiner wird
alleine gelassen hätte er dort statt der
gasumlage die ja Preise erhöht hätte
gleich auf preisdämpfung gesetzt gleich
die Kommission eingesetzt dann hätten
wir diese Bremse jetzt im Winter und die
brauchen wir jetzt im Winter weil die
Bürger und die Betriebe jetzt hart
betroffen sind so soll die Preis wurde
erst wenn es gut geht im März vielleicht
im April kommen und als Brücke so nennt
ist die Kommission so ist eine
Einmalzahlung geben die wirft aber sehr
viele Fragen auf und die wird bestimmt
nicht alle Existenzfragen lösen können
und deshalb ist es falsch dass die
Bundesregierung am Mittwoch angekündigt
hat dass es
betriebshilfeprogramm also das
energiekostenprogramm mit dem Zuschüsse
für Unternehmen gewährt werden die in
Existenznot sind das ist eingestellt
werden sollen nicht alle Existenzfragen
werden durch diese Bremse gelöst werden
und deshalb kritisieren wir dass hier
der Mittelstand alleine gelassen wird
vor Berlin die Expertenkommission hat
auch gesagt wir arbeiten hier natürlich
ein riesengeschwindigkeit man wartet
jetzt noch auf das Endergebnis in drei
Wochen auf die Steuerschätzung wie
schnell geht denn die deutsche
Gesetzgebung denn das was die
Expertenkommission vorgelegt hat ist ja
nur ein Kompromiss dessen man hätte das
viel schöner gestalten können wenn man
diese dusselige gasumlage früher
abgeschafft hätte also ich glaube wir
haben jetzt in den letzten Monaten als
Ampelkoalition zeigt wie schnell wir in
dieser Krise Entscheidungen treffen
können weil das notwendig ist wir haben
sehr viele parlamentarische Prozesse
beschleunigt dann an dieser Stelle auch
nochmal herzlichen Dank an die Union die
als Opposition auch in zahlreichen
Gesprächen auch zugestimmt hat dass wir
zum Beispiel diese Prozesse
beschleunigen weil das natürlich
notwendig ist dass wir in dieser
Krisensituation schnell handeln können
ich möchte nur noch mal kurz darauf
hinweisen dass wir zahlreiche Maßnahmen
ja bereits beschlossen haben und auch
schon Geld bei den Menschen angekommen
ist also zig Milliarden Euro sind ja
schon in den letzten Monaten auch
wenn ich sie unterbrechen darf dank an
die Opposition die Opposition hat ja
schon früher mehreren Monaten so eine
gaspreisbremse vorgelegt ich glaube 75
Prozent sollen gedeckelt werden bei 12
Cent und jetzt sind es 80% laut
Kommission bei 12 sind das hätte man
doch Monate früher haben können und
müssen also die größten
gaspreissteigerungen die stehen sehr
vielen Kunden noch bevor also es stimmt
es gibt Menschen die haben bereits jetzt
einen deutliche Erhöhung ihres Abschlags
per Brief bekommen von ihrem Versorger
aber die noch viel größeren Steigerung
die werden ja in den nächsten Monaten
erst verschickt und deswegen glaube ich
dass es gut ist dass diese Kommission
sehr schnell gearbeitet hat ich bin
allen Mitgliedern sehr sehr dankbar und
ich möchte nur noch mal darauf hinweisen
diejenigen die zum Beispiel Wohngeld
bekommen haben bereits ein
Heizkostenzuschuss auf Ihr Konto
erhalten und das betrifft dann eben auch
alle egal ob sie Gasöl oder mit anderen
heizstoffen eben ihre Wohnung warm
bekommen also an der Kommission liegt es
nicht Deutschland die zurück das haben
wir jetzt klar festgestellt jetzt muss
man damit umgehen aber der Mittelstand
die kleinen Betriebe das Handwerk sagt
das wird nichts mit der Einmalzahlung
der im Dezember wir müssen Januar
Februar überbrücken gerade zum Beispiel
die Bäcker die berühmten Bäcker die auch
viel mit Strom Arbeiten sagen bis dahin
gibt es uns einfach nicht mehr die
brauchen jetzt Unterstützung deshalb ist
es falsch das Programm einzustellen
Robert habe Katja angekündigt ist zu
öffnen für den Mittelstand gerade für
Bäckereien zu öffnen stattdessen soll es
es eingestellt werden das die falsche
Weg und es gibt zum Beispiel Bäckereien
die haben mit staatliche Unterstützung
umgestellt auf Pellets und da haben wir
auch Preissteigerungen von dem doppelten
und dreifachen und der soll gar nichts
gemacht werden deshalb brauchen wir da
antworten und es reicht nicht wenn wir
etwas tun nur für wohnungsempfänger das
ist richtig aber es gibt Menschen die
etwas mehr verdienen und trotzdem hat
betroffen sind
recht da soll nichts gemacht werden bei
Öl und Pellets aber ja nur nach dem
Kommissionsentwurf wenn ich jetzt die
SPD zum Beispiel höre das ist ja nicht
das Gesetz was hier der Bundestag
verabschieden wird wird der Gesetzgeber
da also für diese Menschen noch
nachlegen wir gucken uns das sehr genau
an wir werden das parlamentarisch prüfen
die Regierung prüft ja auch gerade was
ist davon wie umsetzbar natürlich muss
man da verschiedene administrative
Rahmenbedingungen betrachten und diese
Diskussion wird dann hier im Parlament
laufen vielen Dank dass sie da waren es
geht nämlich jetzt los im Deutschen
Bundestag also 200 Milliarden Euro
Wirtschaft stabilisierungsform muss
ermächtigt werden und ich gebe rein
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich wünsche einen schönen
guten Morgen die Sitzung ist eröffnet
die gestern in erster Lesung
der gestern in erster Lesung beratende
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des
heizkostenzuschussgesetzes und des 11
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch auf Drucksache
3.884 soll nachträglich auch dem
Ausschuss für Bildungsforschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung überwiesen
werden sehe sie sind damit einverstanden
kein Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe auf die Zusatzpunkte 8 und 9
erste Beratung des von den Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung
des
stabilisierungsvorgesetztes zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds sowie
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
AFD mit dem Titel keine neuen
Schattenhaushalte begründen für die
Aussprache ist eine Dauer von 39 Minuten
vereinbart
ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort
hat zuerst der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Dr Florian Tonka für die
Bundesregierung
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben über
den Sommer und bis heute anhaltend enorm
hohe Energiepreise und insgesamt eine
bisher in den letzten 70 Jahren nicht
mehr gekannte Entwicklung der Inflation
wir sind zurzeit auf Monatsbasis bei 10%
gesehen sie sind weit überwiegend Folge
des russischen angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und Folge der Strategie der
russischen Führung Europa auch
Deutschland über steigende Energiepreise
über das Abschneiden von Gaslieferungen
politisch und wirtschaftlich unter Druck
zu setzen unsere Gesellschaft zu
destabilisieren um selbst Erfolg zu
haben den sie in ihrer Kriegsführung
bisher nicht gehabt haben diese
Strategie darf nicht aufgehen und wir
verfügen über die Mittel auch zu
verhindern dass diese Strategie aufgeht
und das in unserem Land aufgrund der
russischen Energiepolitik und der
russischen Kriegspolitik Existenzen
gefährdet und vernichtet werden und
genau darum geht es heute mit diesen
abwehrschirmen über den wir debattieren
Herzstück der Vorschläge ist eine
Gaspreis und eine strompreisbremse an
der Konzeption wird mit Hochdruck
gearbeitet das wurde ja auch diese Woche
schon debattiert hier im Haus natürlich
ist die beste Gaspreis und die beste
strompreisbremse Angebot schaffen und
Verbrauch reduzieren beides zusammen
denken beides zusammen denken
und dennoch und dennoch wird es nötig
sein dass der Staat zusätzlich Mittel
mobilisiert um die Folgen für unsere
Gesellschaft abzufedern und um den
Übergang um eine Brücke auch in eine
wieder dauerhaft verlässliche
nachhaltige und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung zu bauen dafür
schlagen wir vor dass 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitgestellt werden über den
bereits in der Pandemie eingeführten
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds der
dafür modifiziert werden soll die
Maßnahmen die wir vorschlagen sollen in
den Jahren noch 2022 überwiegend 2023
und dann 2024 finanziert werden also es
geht darum eine Brücke über die nächsten
beiden Winter zu bauen die Regelung über
den WSF Mittel bereitzustellen hat
enorme Vorteile zum einen kann man auf
diese Weise ein starkes Signal setzen
einen Betrag der ausreicht um die um die
Notwendigkeiten abzudecken bereitstellen
auch überjährig und mit starken Signal
mit der Verlässlichkeit dass die Mittel
eben auch da sind beeinflussen wir auch
Inflationserwartungen so dass das was
wir hier machen der Abwehrschirm auch
eine inflationsbremse ist gerade weil er
dieses starke Signal sendet
und zum zweiten
sind die Mittel die der WSF verwenden
soll strengt zweckgebunden es ist eben
so dass es ganz genau für die vier im
Gesetz vorgeschlagenen Zwecke
gaspreisbremse strompreisbremse
unternehmenshilfen und Unterstützung der
KfW ausgegeben werden darf und auch für
nichts anderes und insofern schaffen wir
es auch die Ressourcen die wir jetzt
mobilisieren müssen wirklich gezielt für
die Bewältigung der Energiekrise und der
Preisspirale einzusetzen und auch für
nichts anderes als das und das ist auch
richtig und wichtig und funktioniert
über den WSF sehr gut
wir haben ich habe schon gesagt vier
Instrumente gaspreisbremse die
strompreisbremse wobei wir bei der
strompreisbremse das ist auch sehr
wichtig für die finanziellen Themen die
wir hier sprechen ja auch mit Einnahmen
rechnen wir wollen die zufallsgewinne
abschöpfen und damit natürlich auch
insbesondere den Strompreis an anderer
Stelle entlasten aber es soll nicht
allein nur ein Zuschuss sein und wir
haben bei den
unternehmensstützungsmaßnahmen natürlich
auch
Beteiligungen die wir eingehen wo man
auch mit Ausgaben aber auch mit
Einnahmen rechnen kann insofern ist auch
noch nicht gesagt aufgrund der
Zusammensetzung der Instrumente wie es
am Ende finanziell ausgehen wird wir
haben ganz klare Ausgaben vor allem im
Bereich der gaspreisbremse und wir haben
einige Instrumente wo es zu Ausgaben
kommen wird aber potenziell jedenfalls
auch zu Einnahmen und ich kann Ihnen
sagen das Bundesfinanzministerium wird
die Möglichkeiten auch Rückflüsse auch
Einnahmen auch Refinanzierung bei den
jeweiligen Instrumenten zu nutzen genau
im Blick behalten und auch zu nutzen
versuchen wir werden ganz klar mit dem
Beschluss über dieses Gesetz nochmals
auch feststellen müssen dass wir uns in
einer außergewöhnlichen Notsituation
befinden die sich der Kontrolle des
Staates entzieht und die staatliche
Finanzlage erheblich beeinträchtigt
Artikel 115 Grundgesetz das hat sich das
ist bereits geltende Beschlusslage
dieses Bundestages für das Jahr 2022 und
die Lage hat sich durch den
vollständigen Wegfall russischer
Gaslieferungen Ende August ja nochmals
deutlich verschärft insofern ist der
erforderliche Veranlassungszusammenhang
zwischen Notlage und den Ausgaben die
wir hier tätigen aus unserer Sicht auch
evident gegeben und rechtfertigt dieses
Engagement es geht darum Schaden von
unserem Land abzuwenden es geht darum
Existenzen zu sichern private Existenzen
wie unternehmerische Existenzen das ist
erstmal ein wichtiges Ziel als solches
aber wenn wir unternehmerische
Existenzen insbesondere auch sichern
Unternehmen helfen durch diese Zeit zu
kommen dann sichern wir uns auch
Steuersubstrat und Einnahmen für die
nächsten Jahre insofern ist es auch
unter dem Gesichtspunkt nachhaltiger
staatlicher Finanzen geboten und
verantwortbar das zu tun was wir hier
vorschlagen ich freue mich auf die
parlamentarischen Beratungen und bedanke
mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
das war Florian Tonka der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretär aus dem
Finanzministerium der hier diesen
Gesetzentwurf vorgestellt hat Matthias
Mittelberg für die
cdu/csu-stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender für den Bereich
Haushalt
es ist gut und das sage ich vorweg dass
die gaspreisbremse jetzt kommt aber man
muss auch dazu sagen endlich kommt sie
sie haben viel Zeit verbraucht in diesem
Sommer mit internen Streitereien bis sie
endlich zu dieser Lösung gekommen sind
sie haben jetzt eine Variante gefunden
aufgrund des Vorschlags der Kommission
Grundbedarf 80% des vorjahresverbrauchs
werden preislich gedeckelt auf 12 Cent
das ist eine Lösung die wir auch
durchaus sachgemäß und richtig finden
sie entspricht auch dem Beschluss
unseres cdu-bundesparteitages schon vom
9 September
als wir beschlossen haben dass wir 75
Prozent des Grundbedarfs zu zwölf Cent
preislich absichern oder Deckeln wollen
so nun haben sie allerdings so viel Zeit
gebraucht für ihre
gaspreisbremse dass die gaspreisbremse
wirklich dann in Kraft tritt wenn die
Menschen Sie wirklich brauchen nämlich
im März wenn der Winter weitgehend
hinter uns ist das ist das
Ergebnis und das müssen sie sich schon
vorhalten lassen die richtigen
Lösungsvorschläge lagen also lange auf
dem Tisch sie haben nur viel zu lange
gebraucht um diese Wege zu erkennen ich
sage ausdrücklich Respekt gegenüber der
Kommission gegenüber der Arbeit der
Kommission die sehr zügig jetzt
gearbeitet hat das gleiche kann man eben
von ihrer Regierungsarbeit wirklich
nicht sagen noch im Juli
noch im Juli und das müssen wir uns alle
in Erinnerung rufen da ist der
Bundeskanzler hat ja so seinen Urlaub
unterbrochen ist extra hier nach Berlin
gefahren und hat eine ganz große
Neuigkeit verkündet das ist nämlich
jetzt die gaspreisbremse das ist die
gasumlage gibt so das hat er dann
verbunden auch mit seinem bekannten Satz
you never walk alone das ist ja eine
tolle Aussage da konnten die Leute auf
einmal verstehen dass meint ich habe
nicht nur die höheren Gaspreise sondern
ich kriege auch noch die Umlage oben
drauf you never walk alone du kriegst
noch die Umlage oben drauf als fetten
zusätzlichen belastungsrucksack das war
ursprünglich ja das war ursprünglich ihr
politischer Ansatz sie wollten den
Leuten die Preise noch zusätzlich
erhöhen dann haben sie monatelang intern
gestritten und jetzt haben sie endlich
erkannt was richtig ist setzen es um
aber jetzt brauchen wir natürlich Monate
in der Umsetzung wenn sie im Juli klug
reagiert hätten und klug gehandelt
hätten dann hätten wir die
gaspreisbremse jetzt schon und sie würde
passend zum Winter in Kraft treten
beim Thema angebots-
[Applaus]
und der Tonka völlig zu Recht
angesprochen da passiert aber bei ihnen
so gut wie nichts sie haben auch da
monatelang gebraucht bis sie unserem
Antrag gefolgt sind den Deckel bei der
Biomasse wegzunehmen sie haben gesagt
sie wollen die Kohlekraftwerke
hochfahren davon sind in Deutschland
gerade zwei mittlerweile am Start
tatsächlich und dann diskutieren sie
noch immer über die Weiternutzung von
drei Kernkraftwerken die jetzt noch
laufen und die die Versorgung von 10
Millionen Bürgern in diesem Land
sicherstellen ich sage auch vor den
Risiken eines wirklichen möglichen
Blackouts ihr Verhalten dazu ist
vollkommen verantwortungslos das 80
Millionen Bundesbürger jetzt noch darauf
warten müssen was ein grüner Parteitag
beschließt das sage ich Ihnen ganz
ehrlich das ist völlig unverantwortlich
für eine Regierungspartei
ihre ich habe eben die Arbeit der
Kommission gelobt und sie setzen jetzt
bei der gaspreisbremse die Arbeit dieser
Kommission deckungsgleich um das haben
sie jetzt jedenfalls so gesagt
maßgebliche Kraft in dieser Kommission
ist Frau Professor Grimm die diese
Konzepte erarbeitet hat dieselbe Frau
Professor Grimm die dem Rat der
Wirtschaftsweisen angehört hat
ausgerechnet wenn wir die drei
Kernkraftwerke weiter nutzen wird der
Strompreis um 8 bis 12 Prozent gesenkt
dass sie diese strompreissenkung den
Bürgern verwehren wollen ist ein Skandal
und nun
und nun zum letzten Punkt man sieht das
dem Kollegen Tonka bildlich nicht an das
ist auch gut so hätte ich fast gesagt
aber die Art und Weise wie sie jetzt
dieses
schuldenkonglomerat sie der eine nennt
das ja doppelwumms der andere spricht
jetzt vom Abwehrschirm sie müssen sich
damit der Titulatur noch einig werden
aber das ist ja das worüber wir heute
eigentlich im Kern sprechen dass wir 200
Milliarden Schulden aufnehmen ohne dass
wir genau wissen wofür das Geld
eigentlich ausgegeben werden soll aber
dazu wollen sie schon mal unsere
Zustimmung haben und was Sie jetzt tun
ist ohne dass Sie wirklich wissen was
finanziert werden soll laden Sie sich
die Hamsterbacken erstmal voll mit einem
Schulden Vorrat da werden die Taschen
voll geladen in diesem Jahr es wird auch
alles auf dieses Jahr gerechnet 2022
damit der Finanzminister dann im
nächsten Jahr künstlich sagen kann ich
halte die Schuldenbremse ein das ist
eigentlich der Hammer in diesem Jahr
insgesamt machen wir 500 Milliarden
zusätzliche Schulden wie 200 Milliarden
doppelwumms die 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr dann machen wir die 140 Milli
die sie jetzt im regulären Haushalt
machen und dann haben sie sich noch die
60 Milliarden aus dem letzten Jahr
geklaut das sind zusammen 500 Milliarden
den Schuldenstand des Bundes erhöhen wir
damit um ein Drittel das ist die höchste
Verschuldung die wir überhaupt jeden
einem Jahr in Deutschland gemacht haben
absoluter superrekord das alles wird
jetzt gerechnet auf dieses Jahr
ausgegeben werden die Gelder tatsächlich
in den nächsten Jahren und da sage ich
Ihnen das ist ein Finanzierungsweg den
wir so nicht mitgehen werden was wir in
der was sie in der Sache tun
gaspreisbremse ist richtig der
Finanzierungsweg ist nicht okay vielen
Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über die
Änderung des stabilisierungs
fondsgesetzes er soll er tüchtigt werden
nämlich mit 200 Milliarden Euro die im
Übrigen in diesem Jahr noch abgestimmt
werden sollen und der nächste rednerste
stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende nein ist er nicht
jetzt kann man selber gucken liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Herr Dr
Mittelberg ich möchte zu Hause
befinden die es in dieser Form das
hatten sie in einem kleinen Satz in
ihrer Rede auch erwähnt so noch nicht
gehabt haben und vor dem Hintergrund gab
es erstens keine Blaupausen die wir aus
der Schublade hätte hätten ziehen können
um sozusagen reibungslos in
Krisenmanagement zu installieren und
zweitens und zweitens haben wir als
Ampelkoalition in dieser Zeit bis jetzt
Entlastungsmaßnahmen auf den Weg
gebracht über drei entlastungs-
Feedback Einmalzahlungen wir haben
Steuerentlastungen auf die Beine
gestellt wir haben am Ende die eg-umlage
abgeschafft wir haben
Mehrwertsteuersätze gesehen für die
Gastronomie und für für die Gaspreise
etc pp das ist etwas wo wir an dieser
Stelle in erheblicher Weise dazu
beigetragen haben die Menschen an dieser
Stelle schon zu entlasten und jetzt
liegt etwas vor womit wir einen nächsten
einen wie ich finde auch entscheidenden
Schritt gehen können wir können mit der
Umwandlung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds mit der
Funktion mit der Erweiterung auf einen
Abwehrschirm hin mit 200 Milliarden Euro
die Menschen entlasten die es am
dringendsten brauchen genau die die
jetzt in Unsicherheit und Angst schweben
die Unternehmen die an dieser Stelle von
Unsicherheit geprägt sind und nicht
wissen wie sie ihre wirtschaftlichen
weiteren Monate planen sollen die jetzt
ihre Abschlagszahlungen für das nächste
Jahr vorliegen haben diesen helfen wir
mit dieser Erweiterung über die
Milliarden Euro weil wir Ihnen in
erheblicher Weise bei der stemmung beim
stemmen und bei der Unterstützung der
des Bezahlens der Energie Gas- und
Strompreise helfen können und das ist
etwas wo diese Regierung keine Zeit
vertrödelt hat wo wir uns im Rahmen der
vorhandenen Möglichkeiten eben auf diese
Expertenkommission bezogen haben und
jetzt ist diese gesetzesmöglichkeit da
das zu verändern und deswegen kann ich
sie jetzt schon darum bitten dieser
Gesetz diesem Gesetzentwurf zuzustimmen
was ich hier was ich hier aber auch noch
mal hervorheben möchte ist und wir haben
es ja an ihrer Rede auch gerade wieder
gehört während in dieser man muss ja so
schon sagen einzigartigen Krise in
dieser Staats- und Wirtschaftskrise in
der wir gerade sind alles zusammengetan
werden muss damit wir unsere
staatspolitischen Verantwortung als
Parlament insgesamt nachkommen können
gibt es einige in diesem Haus die haben
ganz andere Interessenlagen ich wünschte
mir gerade von ihrer Fraktion weil sie
in der Vergangenheit ja also bei der
corona-krisenbewältigung einige
Instrumente ja auf dem Weg gebracht
haben die uns damals gut geholfen haben
dass sie in dieser gleichen Konsequenz
auch heute hinter den Maßnahmen der
Regierung stehen weil wir dann natürlich
auch eine ganz andere Kraft nach draußen
an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger vermelden
können das zweite und das will ich aber
auch sagen ist
dass wir dass wir auch Abgeordnete vor
allem aus ihrer Fraktion der AFD haben
die diese existenzielle Krise der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Unternehmen
dafür nutzen durch durch
verschwörungsmythen durch durch Lügen
durch Hetze die Bevölkerung in ihrer
unsicheren Lage sogar noch dagegen
aufzubringen sie spalten die
Gesellschaft ihr Geschäftsmodell ist es
diese Krise zu nutzen und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in ihren Sorgen
zu benutzen um ihr politisches Kalkül
daraus zu ziehen und das ist einfach
schäbig
die Ampelkoalition hat sich an dieser
Stelle zu einem großen Maßnahmepaket
verständigt und ich denke dass wir mit
dem Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds in
der Umwandlung zum Abwehrschirm einen
weiteren wichtigen Schritt gehen wir
werden das sagte ich schon die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die dringend
darauf warten sie alle warten darauf zu
wissen was wird mit den Rechnungen ab
September ab Januar für das nächste Jahr
dieses Geld was wir jetzt locker machen
können über diese Gesetzesänderung wird
Ihnen helfen damit sie ihre Rechnungen
besser bezahlen können das ist der
richtige Weg das ist der Kurs den Olaf
Scholz und diese Ampelkoalition
einschlägt damit helfen wir den Menschen
und überbrücken eine nächste wichtige
Zeit und wir wissen alle in dieser
Ampelkoalition weil wir uns
verantwortungsbewusst dieser Krise
stellen dass wir offen für die
Notwendigkeiten sind auch nächste und
weitere Schritte durchzugehen wenn sie
denn nötig sind die 200 Milliarden Euro
mit dieser Modifizierung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungs ist zumindest
ein nächster ein guter ein wichtiger
Schritt und ich bitte Sie noch mal um
Zustimmung in diesem Gesetz vielen Dank
und das war natürlich Frank junge meine
Damen und Herren ich bitte noch mal
entschuldigung das war wirklich
innerhalb von Sekunden getauscht ich
sehe Matthias Milster reden sollte auch
nicht im Plenum vielleicht kann er nicht
da sein ist nicht da insofern ist Frank
junge da scheinbar eingesprungen Peter
Böhringer jetzt der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Mitbürger die
Regierung weiß gar nicht was konkret Sie
heute hier vorlegt jedenfalls sagt sie
es uns im Gesetzestext nicht im Entwurf
ergibt sich die Bundesregierung in Wagen
Andeutungen über staatliche Programme
zur Abfederung von Preissteigerung beim
Bezug von Gas und Strom aber es gibt
darin nicht ein Wort wie diese Programme
ausgestaltet werden sollten wer bekommt
Geld welche Preise werden wo gedeckelt
wie soll die Sache operativ umgesetzt
werden all das werden Fragen die dieser
Bundestag natürlich wissen müsste bevor
über solche gewaltige Verschuldung auch
nur debattiert werden kann
das vorgelegte Gesetz wird das ist
bereits sicher ein bürokratisches
Monstrum hervorbringen der
eigentümerverband Haus und Grund
bezeichnet das Vorhaben der
gaspreiskommission als nicht umsetzbar
es sei von Leuten erarbeitet die noch
nie eine Heizkostenabrechnung gesehen
haben
dieser Bundestag soll zustimmen dass 200
Milliarden Euro neue Schulden in einen
zweckentfremdeten nebenhaushalt ich sage
bewusst auch Schattenhaushalt gepackt
werden es ist absurd der Regierung mal
eben über den Verordnungsweg einen
halben Jahreshaushalt freizugeben und
selbst diese Riesensumme wird nur für
etwa 15 Monate ausreichen wir sagen nein
zu diesem Blankoscheck
die AFD kann der Neuauflage des WSF
nicht zustimmen der doch 2020
ausschließlich gegen die angebliche
Jahrhundertkatastrophe namens Corona ins
Leben gerufen wurde oder in ihren Worten
Herr Tonka ihre Zitat von eben die
Mittel sind strikt zweckgebunden ja
genauso klang das auch im März 2020 an
dieser Stelle genau zum gleichen
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds die
Mittel sind strikt auf Corona
zweckgebunden was daraus wurde sehen wir
ja heute
die nun geplante Reaktivierung Umwidmung
und Vergrößerung auf Pump und auf Vorrat
des WSF ist Rainer Missbrauch einer
Notstandslage man will mit
exekutivmaßnahmen also Verordnung ohne
Rücksicht auf Zwänge knappen steuergelds
durchregieren das hat mit
parlamentarischer Kontrolle nichts mehr
zu tun
das Gasheizer auch noch bevorzugt werden
gegenüber ölheizen ja das macht das
Projekt rechtlich sogar noch weiter
angreifbar die planwirtschaftlichen
Maßnahmen von Strom und gaspreisdeckeln
sind vermeidbar die energiepression ist
Politik gemacht noch können Sie die
kommende Massenverarmung verhindern
indem sie endlich die Ursachen abstellen
für eine nur symptomatische Linderung
mit Steuergeld sind die schadensummende
nötig ist also das Abwenden der für
menschenunternehmen existenziell
gefährlichen energienotstands des
energienotstands im Winters sie müssen
endlich den Irrweg der co2-modelltheorie
verlassen also heimische Kohle nutzen
zudem sichere Kernkraft sie müssen in
dieser Lage auch die für Deutschland so
verteilen Sanktionen gegen russisches Öl
und Gas aufgeben konkret muss auch wenn
sie es alle nicht hören wollen sofort
der noch intakt des Strang von Nords
schön genutzt werden über 30 Millionen
30 Millionen gasabnehmer in Deutschland
könnten alleine nur dadurch sofort
kostengünstig versorgt werden so wie es
die letzten Jahre auch immer war das
liegt im Interesse Deutschlands und
Europas da nur dieses pipeline-gas
wirklich Versorgungssicherheit
ermöglicht
die Regierung hofft stattdessen auf
einen warmen Winter als auf die böse
Erwärmung die man doch eigentlich
verhindern will und bekämpfen will
sie hofft auch auf Gas ausgerechnet aus
Katar und als arbeitshan obwohl man doch
angeblich wertebasierte Außenpolitik
machen will sie hofft auf polnischen
Kohlestrom den man doch eigentlich
ablehnt und sie hofft auf französische
Kernkraft die man doch eigentlich hasst
und bekämpft so absurd ist deutsche
Regierungspolitik und auch
Oppositionspolitik
2122 herzlichen Dank
200 Milliarden Euro ertüchtigen soll der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds erfahren
darum geht die Diskussion hier ist wenn
Christian kindner von den Bündnis grünen
haushaltspolitische Sprecher ist der
nächste Redner meine Damen und Herren
wir befinden uns in der schwersten Krise
seit Jahrzehnten
die corona-pandemie ist noch lange nicht
vorbei und die Klimakatastrophen das
Arten aussterben eskaliert immer mehr
wir haben diesen Sommer gesehen was das
heißt bei brennen in Brandenburg bei
fremdenharz der Rhein ist ausgetrocknet
vor dort der Fader die schlimmste Dürre
seit 500 Jahren in Europa und als wäre
das alles noch nicht schlimm genug für
das russische Regime ein brutalen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukrain gegen die
demokratische Ukraine
und das führt zu einer harten Krise auf
fossile Energie in Europa denn russische
Diktator Wladimir Putin versucht mit
fossilen Gas die demokratischen
Unterstützer der Ukraine zu spalten und
unsere Gesellschaft ist destabilisieren
aber wir sagen sehr klar das werden wir
als Koalition nicht zulassen mit der
schätzen weiter die Ukraine die wir
lassen uns und Wladimir Putin nicht
spalten
und wir haben als Ampelkoalition in den
letzten Monat zentrale Antworten auf
Putins Hybride Kriegsführung geleistet
wir haben die Gasspeicher zu 95% gefüllt
wir haben das größte Paket von
erneuerbaren Energien seit Jahrzehnten
im Bundestag beschlossen wir haben drei
entlastungspakete der Staatssekretär
darauf hingewiesen in Höhe von 95
Milliarden Euro beschlossen heute legen
wir eine weitere zentrale Antwort vor
ein 200 Milliarden Euro schweren
abwehrschirmen wir machen aus dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
zu Stabilisierung unserer Gesellschaft
und das sind 200 Milliarden Euro die
direkt ankommen die unsere gasvorsorge
stabilisieren die industriestabilisieren
die kleine mittlere Unternehmen helfen
sozialen Einrichtungen Kommunen und vor
allem die Bürgerinnen und Bürger von den
schlimmsten Folgen der fossilen
Preissteigerung schützen wir sagen sehr
klar wir lassen sehr Krise niemanden
allein
und deswegen schlagen wir vor das 200
Milliarden Euro an neuen Krediten im
Rahmen der Regeln des Grundgesetzes
Artikel
115/2022 noch aufgenommen werden um die
Maßnahmen gegen fossile Inflation bei
gasfernwärme und Strom zu finanzieren
wir machen das auch in diesem Jahr noch
in voller Höhe um auf Verlässlichkeit
und überjährigkeit zu garantieren denn
diese Mitte sollen ja auch für mehrere
Jahre bis früher
2024 oder Mitte 2024 Verfügung stehen
wir gehen damit eben auch finanziell
jetzt weil es notwendig ist in
Vorleistung und zeigen damit dass wir
eine aktiven Finanzpolitik jenseits
ideologischer abonniertheit pragmatisch
entschlossen in der Krise handeln
und ich bin den Mitgliedern der
Expertenkommission für Gas und Wärme
dankbar dass sie es wirklich in der
extremen Zeitung
Zwischenbericht vorgelegt haben und ein
komplexen Vorschlag gearbeitet haben der
eine weitere gute Grundlage für unser
parlamentarisches Verfahren ist
natürlich ist es klar dass wir uns im
parlamentarischer fahren die Vorschläge
auch noch mal angucken müssen dass unser
Aufgaben im Parlament zu dem Sicherheit
noch einfach rechtliche Fragen geben es
geht um technische teils natürlich
werden wir in manchen Stellen auch
politisch eigene Akzente setzen müssen
zum Beispiel der Frage einer Obergrenze
auch insbesondere im Bereich der
Industrie und wir müssen auch nochmal um
das Thema Energieeffizienz und
Sparanreize reden denn eins ist auch
klar neben der Subventionierung auch der
Preise brauchen wir auch eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Kraftanstrengung
zum Sparen von Gas eine Signal kann es
auch nicht sein mit dem Preis ist schon
alles gut wir müssen weiterhin zentral
dieser Krise gaseinspannung eine
gefährliche gasmangelage insbesondere
für die Industrie zu verhindern darum
uns jetzt auch in diesem Winter
und der Mittelberg sie haben gesagt die
Union unterstützt im Kern die Vorschläge
zur strompreisbremse und gaspreisbremse
gleichzeitig haben sie gesagt aber die
Finanzierung unterstützen sie nicht was
wollen denn stattdessen sie müssen auch
konkrete Vorschläge machen nur
kritisieren geht er nicht wollen sie
Steuern erhöhen wollen sie
Sozialkürzungen was wollen die konkret
sie müssen konkret hier Parlament sagen
was sie wollen das wäre seriöse
Finanzpolitik
und der Mitte Berg sie haben auch die
Atomkraft angesprochen Herr Merz sind
heute auch hier sind nur drei Tage vor
der Landtagswahl Niedersachsen gesagt
der Mittelberg und ich komme ja beide
aus Niedersachsen wissen also sehr gut
wie die Lage dort ist Herr Merz immer
noch drei Tage oder Land Niedersachsen
gesagt die Wählerinnen und Wähler
entscheiden auch in dieser
Volksabstimmung über die Atomkraft das
Ergebnis ist bekannt die CDU hat das
schlechtes Ergebnis seit 65 Jahren die
Grünen haben das historisch beste
Ergebnis in ihrer Geschichte die
stärkste Kraft ist die SPD geworden es
gibt jetzt eine rot-grüne
Landesregierung wird es in Niedersachsen
geben Herr Merz die Wählerin Wähler
haben sehr klar bei dieser
Volksabstimmung über Atomkraft
entschieden
und ehrlich
und Liebe Union lasst uns mal ehrlich
reden warum sind wir in dieser fossilen
Energiekrise das sieht auch daran dass
wir 16 Jahre Energiepolitik der Union
hatten da müssen sie gar nicht lachen
ich komme zu den Fakten wir werden uns
alle noch an den Altmaier Knick bei der
Solarenergie wir wissen auch dass sie
versucht haben jedes Windrads blockieren
wo es geht und in der Führung von Angela
Merkel wurden die gasspeichern Reden an
gaskom verkauft der Führung von Angela
Merkel wo der PTK Schwedt an Rossner
verkauft Nord Stream 2 wurde dafür von
Angela Merkel vorangetrieben das waren
ihre 16 Jahre Regierungszeit Misere
gebracht haben wir räumen jetzt den
Hochdruck auf was sie uns alles erlassen
haben
vielen Dank Sven Christian Kindler von
den Bündnis grünen heute Haar Abend
haben die Grünen ihren Parteitag das
nennt sich bei den Grünen Bundes
Delegierten Konferenz in Bonn und
Phoenix meine Damen und Herren wird das
Ganze für sie live übertragen bis
Mitternacht und nehmen sich ein bisschen
Zeit heute Abend wird da heftigungen
werden um die Frage Atomkraft und das
alles wie gesagt hier bei uns auf diesem
Sender zu sehen jetzt die stellvertreten
Fraktionsvorsitzende Linksfraktion
und Armutsbetroffene dürfen nicht länger
arm bleiben das ist die klare Forderung
der LINKEN und daran messen wir jedes
Gesetz meine Damen und Herren
besser verdienen und Vermögende freuen
sich jetzt schon über die gaspreisbremse
Marcel Fratzscher Chef des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung legt
den Finger in die Wunde Menschen mit
hohem Einkommen werden viermal mehr Geld
als Menschen mit niedrigem Einkommen
erhalten sie wollen alles über den Preis
Regeln doch das ist der falsche Weg denn
es trifft vor allem die Menschen mit
unterem und mittleren Einkommen wir
brauchen andere Maßnahmen meine Damen
und Herren
ein Großteil des privaten
Energieverbrauchs lässt sich aber den
Menschen zuordnen die mehrere Häuser
besitzen Swimmingpools haben schwere SUV
oder
sportwarenfragen und die vor allem
häufig mit dem Flugzeug auch mit dem
Privatflugzeug verreisen warum also ganz
konkreter Vorschlag nicht im Winter alle
suv-sportwagen Luxusyachten und
Privatjets stilllegen das wäre doch mal
eine wirksame konkrete Maßnahme meine
Damen und Herren ich sage der Koalition
ganz klar sie dürfen sich nicht weiter
als Vermögensverwalter der oberen
reichsten zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung
verstehen das werden wir nicht
akzeptieren meine Damen und Herren
die SPD und ihre diversen
Koalitionspartner haben schon viele
Bremsen entworfen funktioniert haben sie
für die große Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger alle nicht ich erinnere zum
Beispiel an die gescheiterte
mietpreisbremse die Wohnungsnot war noch
nie so groß wie heute sie haben ein
neues Ministerium geschaffen aber auf
die Wohnung warten wir immer noch das
ist wahrlich eine schlechte Bilanz meine
Damen und Herren die Energie
den ziehen und Lebensmittelpreise
explodieren wir brauchen endlich
wirksame preisdecke und dazu gehören die
Energiekonzerne endlich wieder in die
öffentliche Hand meine Damen und Herren
ich fordere Sie auch kuscheln sie nicht
vor den wohnungskonzernen den großen
Lebensmittelkonzern und den
energiemonopolen die Süddeutsche Zeitung
wahrlich im Kampfblatt der Linken hat am
vergangenen Wochenende vorgerechnet wen
sie mit ihrer Energiepolitik brutal in
den Bankrott treiben und wer mit der
Energiepolitik kein Problem hat bringen
das auf den Punkt die reichsten zehn
Prozent der deutschen Haushalte
beanspruchen so viel Energie wie die
Ärmsten 40 Prozent und das wohlhabendste
Zehntel der Bevölkerung könnte auf einen
Schlag auf einen Schlag etwa 26 Prozent
des Energiebedarfs der deutschen
Haushalte einsparen wenn sie sich so
verhalten würden wie der
durchschnittlich wohlhabende Bürger das
wäre doch nicht zu viel verlangt meine
Damen und Herren also verbessern wir das
Gesetz mit konkreten Maßnahmen hören sie
auf ständig an die Allgemeinheit zu
appellieren sondern treffen sie dort
Entscheidungen wo sie wirksam sind
nämlich bei den reichsten in diesem Land
herzlichen Dank
für die SPD ich gucke jetzt noch mal
jawohl redet jetzt Nina Scheer sie ist
Sprecherin für Umwelt und Energie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Kolleg
innen und einen Passus aus dem
Gesetzentwurf Vorlesen die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sowie Unternehmen sollen
darauf vertrauen können Herr Mittelberg
ich bitte Sie kurz zuzuhören die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sowie Unternehmen
sollen darauf vertrauen können dass der
Abwehrschirm mit ausreichenden
finanziellen Ressourcen ausgestattet ist
dieses Vertrauen dieses Vertrauen
sprechen wollen sie den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern offenbar nicht geben weil sie
hier gerade grundsätzlich abgelehnt
haben diesen
Programms zuzustimmen weil sie offenbar
nicht für nötig halten dass dieses
Volumen erforderlich ist um genau dieses
Vertrauen zu gewährleisten um genau
dieses Vertrauen zu geben und das finde
ich im höchsten Maße irritierend dass
sie auf dieser Ebene in diesen Zeiten
ein solches Vertrauen den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern nicht geben wollen das
möchte ich mal festhalten die CDU CSU
ist nicht bereit dieses Vertrauen zu
geben
und genau an diesem Vertrauen setzt eben
dieses Gesetz an wir brauchen dieses
Gesetz um den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
auszustatten mit 200 Milliarden und eben
diese Möglichkeit damit zu geben Hilfen
die dann durch auszugestaltende
Programme auch wirklich umgesetzt werden
können insofern ist es auch falsch die
ist vom rechten Rand im Parlament hier
unterstellt wird dass hier quasi eine
Selbstentmachtung des Parlaments
stattfände nein das ist so nicht sondern
es ist eine zu Verfügungstellung mit
grundgesetzlich fundierter Basis für
diese 200 Milliarden weil wir alle nicht
wissen wie weit die Abhängigkeiten die
wir zurzeit von Russland noch hatten die
letzten Monate und in auf gutem Weg sind
uns davon zu befreien wie weit die Krise
die daraus auf dem fossilen Energiemarkt
erwachsen ist und von der wir uns
loslösen wollen wie weit diese Krise
auch finanz
weitere fördern erfordert und genau da
setzen wir verantwortungsbewusst
[Musik]
Vertrauen und zu Stabilisierung von
Vertrauen in Handlungsfähigkeit an
deswegen ist es erforderlich dass wir
diesen
stabilisierungsfond
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsform machen
und insofern kann man auch nur an alle
appellieren hier keine Fragezeichen zu
setzen weil damit sind sie nur
nährbodenberater für Angst und Angst ist
einfach genau das was dann wieder
ausgenutzt wird um unsere
parlamentarische Demokratie auszuhüllen
damit geben sie sich in sehr schlechte
Gesellschaft wenn Sie diese Angst weiter
spüren
wir haben in dieser Situation wir haben
eine ernste Situation und diese
ernstesituation verlangen zum Beispiel
auch dass wir über den Teich blicken und
schauen was andere Staaten und
Kontinente machen wir haben in den USA
ein Inflation reaction
reduction Act es wird reagiert auf
Inflation des wird reagiert auf die
Krise es wird es wird darauf reagiert
dass wir eine Klimakrise haben und
massiv investiert wenn wir nicht
aufpassen dann kann diese sinnvolle
Maßnahme die die USA ergreifen auch
bedeuten dass in dieser steigenden
Inflation die wir in Europa haben
aufgrund der fossilen energiepreiskrise
dass wir daraufhin verstärkt
Schwierigkeiten bekommen auch in
Investitionen in erneuerbare Energien in
den Transformationsprozess den wir haben
deswegen ist es dringend nötig dass wir
Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen auf den Weg
bringen weitere Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
wir haben ja schon gehandelt die auch
kräftig genug sind dass diese
fortschreitende Inflation eingedämmt
wird dafür muss man bei den
Energiepreisen in Form von Gaspreisen
strompreisbremse ansetzen damit dieser
Weg gestoppt wird dass die Inflation
gestoppt wird dass wieder investiert
werden kann auch in die Transformation
massiv investiert werden kann weil sonst
droht uns tatsächlich Abwanderung in
auch solche Länder die jetzt ein Booster
ansetzen und angesetzt haben gerade um
diesen Transformationsprozess zu
beschleunigen wir müssen hier gleich
aufbleiben mit diesen Bemühungen die
auch an anderer Stelle bleiben damit wir
wirtschaftlich nicht da
benachteiligt sind in Deutschland und
Europa Deutschland ist ein
Hochtechnologie
wir wollen das bleiben mit Europa in
Europa und in Deutschland das heißt
intransformationsprozess massive
Investitionen in erneuerbare Energien
und wenn sie von Seiten der Union immer
wieder versuchen der BEV Sand in die
Augen zu streuen das Atomenergie hier
die Lösung sei da möchte ich doch mal
ganz erklärtermaßen dagegen setzen dass
diese drei verbleibenden Atomkraftwerke
und nur die zwei haben hat der
Stresstest in die identifiziert im Süden
Deutschlands dass sie nur einen
minimalen Beitrag für den allergrößten
Worst Case zeichnen können und wir haben
gerade erst vor zwei Wochen im Deutschen
Bundestag gerade erst vor zwei Wochen im
Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen einen
erneuerbaren Energien Booster der
übrigens noch nicht vom Stresstest mit
berücksichtigt werden konnte darin haben
wir eine verstärkte Auslastung von
Bioenergie beschlossen wir haben eine
verstärkte Auslastung von Windenergie
und für Photovoltaik reparing alles
dergleichen beschlossen insofern
versuchen Sie nicht hier nicht
Nebelkerzen zu werfen die Energiewende
die Energiewende ist das Ziel und der
Weg um diese Krise zu bewältigen und
brauchen wir den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds und
diese Fragezeichen die sie hier setzen
sind nur Destabilisierung und
Angstmacherei das ist unverantwortlich
vielen Dank
erste Lesung der Bundestag wird den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
corona-zeiten übrig ist mit einer
kreditermischung noch in diesem Jahr von
200 Milliarden Euro ausstatten darum
geht es hier in dieser Debatte die jetzt
gleich enden wird mit dem letzten Redner
Florian Osna von der CSU Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Preise für Gas-
Pellets und Strom schießen seit Monaten
durch die Decke und was macht die Ampel
während der gesamten Sommerzeit
nichts nichts anstatt für Entlastung bei
den Bürgern zu sorgen hat der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
den ich übrigens heute vermisse übrigens
viele der Bundesminister aus seine
einzige Bundesministerin desee also für
200 Milliarden Euro doppelbums hätte mir
gedacht wäre es höher priorisiert
seitens der Bundesregierung
anstatt für Entlastungen bei den Bürgern
zu sorgen hat Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Habeck von den Grünen ja sogar noch mit
einer von ihm erdachten Gas Umlage eine
zusätzliche Belastung beschlossen das
ist wirklich keine unseren Land mit
gesunden Menschenverstand
nachvollziehbar es war deshalb mehr als
Überfälle unter Druck der cdocs zu
Bundestagsfraktion zumindest die sie
Zusatz transalierung gasumlage für
unsere bürgeradakter zu legen
insofern ist der sieben Grundsatz
richtig dass so ein überhaupt eine
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und Unternehmen in unserem Land
kommt allerdings sollte man nicht von
einem doppelwumms sprechen sondern eher
von einem schuldenwumms denn dieser
sogenannte Abwehrschirm ist nichts
weiter als ein gigantischer
Schattenhaushalt der mit einer
Schuldenaufnahme über 200 Milliarden
Euro die Hamsterbacken der Ampel füllt
diese Schulden müssen auch irgendwann
abbezahlt werden 60 Milliarden Euro aus
dem alten Jahr 140 Milliarden Euro
corona-schulden 100 Milliarden
sonderschulden Bundeswehr und nur
nochmals 200 Milliarden Euro
Krisenintervention in Summe eine halbe
Billion Euro in diesem Jahr als ein
kompletter Bundeshaushalt das gleicht
schon einer Öffnung aller
schuldenschleusen für uns als Ziele und
CSU muss deshalb unbedingt eine
komplette neu Priorisierung des
Bundeshaushalts vorgenommen
Herr Oster gestatten Sie eine Frage vom
Kollegen schrodi aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter ooster vielen Dank dass
Sie die Frage zulassen wir haben jetzt
von Reden an der cdu/csu-fraktion jetzt
mehrmals gehört dass sie ja
grundsätzlich richtig finden dass es
Entlastungen gibt dass es Hilfsprogramme
gibt für die Unternehmen unserem Land
für die Menschen unter unserem Land die
und in hohen Preisen leiden wir bringen
das nun auf dem Weg aber gleichzeitig
sagen sie sie sind nicht einverstanden
mit der Finanzierung dieser notwendigen
Programme aber sie haben jetzt mehrmals
bei mehreren Rednern kann der einzige
Alternative aufgemacht wie sie nun diese
Programme finanzieren sie wollen weder
Steuern erhöhen noch wollen sie mit
neuen Kreditprogrammen das ganze auf den
Weg bringen die Frage ist wenn sie
einerseits solche Dinge versprechen und
andererseits seit Monaten eine Antwort
schuldig sind wie sie es finanzieren
wollen dann ist das unseriöse
Finanzpolitik die sie sich in der
Opposition leisten können aber nicht wir
eine Frage ganz konkret wie wollen sie
es finanzieren
ja sehr geehrte Herr Kollege vielen Dank
für die für frage sie haben sich selbst
schon fast die Antwort gegeben sie haben
in dem instrumentariumkasten der SPD
benannt dass man entweder Steuern erhöht
oder dass man selbst neue Schulden
aufnimmt aber es gibt es gibt auch noch
andere Möglichkeiten nämlich eine neue
Priorisierung des Haushalts ich denke
wir haben wir hatten diese Woche wir
hatten diese Woche
wir hatten diese Woche ein Bürgergeld
ein Bürgergeld diskutiert ich denke es
ist eine Unzeit in dieser Zeit ein
Bürgergeld über Millionen und Milliarden
in diesem Land zu beschließen statt eine
neue Priorisierung des Bundeshaushalts
vorzunehmen
bevor wir jetzt hier ist kein
Zwiegespräch glaube er hat die Frage
wann Herr osner es gibt aber noch eine
Frage vom Kollegen Fricke aus der
FDP-Fraktion würden sie die auch noch
zulassen
Herr Fricke sie haben das Wort
Herr Kollege weil ich die kluge Frage
meines Kollegen schrodi ja verstehe ich
aber mit der Antwort auch nicht
zufrieden bin und ich auch nicht bisher
im Haushaltsausschuss in den Beratung
auch nicht in dieser Woche erlebt habe
dass die cdu/csu auch nur einen Antrag
wirklich zur neu Priorisierung gestellt
hat versuche ich es
versuche ich es
mit einer vielleicht ganz einfachen
Frage ich habe dem Kollegen Mittelberg
zugehört ich habe ihnen zugehört da wird
gesagt ja das muss alles anders ich habe
aber etwas nicht gehört was man sonst in
ihren Reden immer so deutlich und klar
hört gerade von der stolzen CSU werden
sie denn dann den Gesetzentwurf jetzt
ablehnen oder bekomme ich jetzt von
ihnen ein weiches jein weil wir ja
neuperiorisieren
sehr geehrter Herr Kollege fricki auch
da herzliches Dankeschön für Ihre Frage
also erstmal um die Frage beantworten zu
können ob wir zustimmen können müssen
wir genau wissen was wirklich am Ende
umgesetzt wird hier lassen Sie es derart
viele Fragezeichen die selbst Vorredner
ihrer Ampelkoalition zu bereits
bestätigt haben zweitens wir hatten in
allen Haushaltsdebatten immer ganz klar
auch die Gegenfinanzierung mit
angebracht teilweise sogar mit einer
Größen Gegenfinanzierung im Gegensatz
zur Ampel die immer nur zusätzliche
Beschlüsse on top auf den bestehenden
Haushalt gesetzt hat im Gegensatz zu
ihnen wissen wir sehr wohl mit den
öffentlichen Geldern umzugehen
ob die ob die Schulden Ausnahmesituation
auf wären wir beim Punkt des Artikels
115 für den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform Ende wirklich greift
bleibt noch zu klären exogene Notlagen
wieder Energie Engpass durch den Ukraine
Krieg liegen vor jedoch muss der Bund
nicht wehrlos zuschauen Stichwort
Kernkraftwerke und da möchte gerne auf
meinem vorigen als wenn Christian Kinder
von den Grünen reagieren als aus grüner
auf andere mit erhobenen Zeigefinger zu
deuten ist echt mehr als gewagt denn ab
Baden-Württemberg hat von allen
Flächenländern die wenigsten
Windkraftanlagen ist aber bekannterweise
seit 2011 von einem grünen Minister von
einem grünen Ministerpräsident
Kretschmann regiert Bayern im Gegensatz
das seit 1957 durchgehend von der c- zu
regiert ist hat die höchste Quote an
regenerativen Energien da können sich
selbst beantworten welche politischen
Voraussetzungen am Ende
die Krise muss definitiv abgefedert
werden und es zwingt uns natürlich
verzichtbarer Projekte im Kernhaushalt
einzusparen ich habe es vorher schon
benannt beispielsweise Bürgergeld denn
es anders als insbesondere die Grünen in
den letzten Tagen immer wieder weiß
machen wollen kommt das Geld eben
einfach nicht von einer politisch
gelenkten Zentralbank und man kann auch
sehr wohl in seiner eigenen Währung man
höre pleite gehen wer die Grundsätze
einer unabhängigen Zentralbank aufgibt
geht den Weg in die hypeinflation den
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang in
Deutschland mehrmals in der Geschichte
erlebt hat das ist mit uns als cducs so
nicht zu machen
bekämpfen also Union für eine Entlastung
der bürgerunternehmen jedoch ist es
nicht nachvollziehbar nach welcher
Kalkulation frau Präsidentin komme zum
Schluss auf die Summe von 200 Milliarden
Euro kommt ist bleibt völlig offen wie
Gas und Strompreise schlussendlich
ausgestaltet werden soll Öl und Pellets
fallen völlig was aus meiner Sicht
gerade den ländlichen Traum trifft keine
Frage ich will die Herausforderung nicht
kleinreden es ist gigantisch wir laufen
in eine dehnen australisierung unseres
Landes mit unabsehbaren Folgen für
Wohlstand und der deutschen
Zukunftsfähigkeit wir werden uns einer
konstruktiven Zusammenarbeit deshalb
nicht verschließen unsere Zustimmung
lieber Otto Fricke hängt am Ende aber
von der konkreten Ausgestaltung ab
herzliches Vergelt's Gott fürs zuhören
Florian ossen hat gesagt die CDU CSU
möchte erstmal wissen was am Schluss in
diesem Gesetz dann drinsteht in dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds soll
nicht nur eine Kredit Ermächtigung von
200 Milliarden Euro
ausgestattet werden sondern auch die
Regelungen zu Finanzierung der geplanten
Hilfen muss darin festgehalten werden
und die sind ja noch alles andere als
klar das war aber heute erst der erste
Gesetzentwurf es geht jetzt in den
entsprechenden Ausschüsse und man muss
jetzt warten welche Gesetze im Einzelnen
und wie es im einzelnen mit der
gaspreisbremse zum Beispiel aussieht das
wird ja noch ein wenig auf sich warten
lassen der nächste Tagesordnungspunkt da
geht es um das Jahressteuergesetz 2022
in diesem Jahr Steuergesetz sollen auch
wie in anderen Jahren handwerkliche
Änderungen im Steuerrecht vorgenommen
werden wichtige Punkte sollen mehr
Solaranlagen auf Dächern von privaten
Häusern gefördert werden Beiträge zu
Rentenversicherung sollen bereits ab dem
kommenden Jahr voll von der Steuer
absetzbar sein die Homeoffice Pauschale
in Höhe von 5 € pro Tag soll weiterhin
gewährt werden der Spitzenausgleich für
besonders energieintensive Unternehmen
wird um ein Jahr verlängert der Sparer
Pauschbetrag soll von 8001 auf 1.000
Euro starken
steigen mein Gott und der erste Redner
hat jetzt auch schon das Rednerpult
erreicht Christoph Meyer von
fdpes in verschiedenen Bereichen des
Steuerrechts notwendige Ergänzung zum
Verbesserungsbedarf ergeben diesen
Bedarf finden wir jetzt hier in Entwurf
des Jahressteuergesetzes 2022 wieder den
wir heute in erster Lesung beraten
eigentlich hätte mein Kollege Markus
Herbrand gerne diese Rede gehalten er
musste sich überraschend in
Selbstisolation bewegen ich möchte die
Gelegenheit nutzen Ihnen zunächst
erstmal einen milden Verlauf zu wünschen
ich glaube die Ampel setzt mit diesen
Entwurf ein Zeichen auch im Steuerrecht
wie wir auf der einen Seite sozial
ausgewogen auf der anderen Seite aber
auch ökonomisch und ökologisch klug
handeln ich möchte Ihnen zunächst einige
Kleinigkeiten nennen die in diesen
Gesetzentwurf jetzt neu geregelt werden
zum ersten der Zuschlag zur Grundrente
wird zukünftig steuerfrei gestellt das
ist für die Betroffenen eine wirklich
großartige Sache wir haben
endlich die Abschreibung im
Mietwohnungsbau von zwei auf drei
Prozent erhöhte damit wir die
pauschalitenutzungsdauer im Wohnungsbau
oder bei Wohnimmobilien der Realität
eher anpassen wir haben oder in Fristen
die
homeoffice-pauschale
fünf Euro pro Tag maximal 1000 Euro im
Jahr es wird höchste Zeit hier
die Homeoffice Möglichkeiten an die
moderne Arbeitswelt anzupassen
wir werden wir werden die
Absetzbarkeit von Arbeitszimmern endlich
einfacher Regeln ebenfalls durch eine
jahrespauschbetrag von 1.250 Euro wir
werden die zur Vermeidung der
Doppelbesteuerung von Renten den
vollständigen Sonderausgabenabzug von
Altersvorsorgeaufwendungen auf das Jahr
2023 vorziehen auch da kann man
klatschen nicht alle klatschen wir
werden den Sparer Pauschbetrag sehr gut
wir werden den Sparer Pauschbetrag zum
ersten ersten 2023 um 200 Euro auf 1000
Euro bzw 2000 Euro für zusammen
veranlagt erhöhen den steuerlichen
ausbildungsfallbetrag erhöhen wir das
heißt ein ganzer Strauß von wichtigen
Entlastungsmaßnahmen der am Ende den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in unserem Land
zugute kommen wird und für uns steht
neben diesem Punkten zweifelsohne der
Abbau von steuerlichen investitionsen
und die Schaffung von gezielten Anreizen
bei der Produktion von Sonnenenergie auf
Wohngebäuden im Fokus wir wollen
Bürokratie abbauen und wir wollen dass
zumindest kleine Betreiber von
PV-Anlagen zukünftig möglichst gar
nichts mehr mit dem Finanzamt zu tun
haben und umgekehrt auch das Finanzamt
möglichst nichts mit dem Betreibern
dieser kleinen Anlagen
und
wenn wir uns vergegenwärtigen wir haben
ja in der Rede Runde davor alle über die
Herausforderungen die den nächsten
Jahren vor uns stehen zusammen
diskutiert dann ist genau der Punkt der
dezentralen Energieversorgung ein
Mosaikstein den wir heben können wo wir
auf der einen Seite einen beträchtliches
Entlastungsvolumen für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger schaffen können und auf der
anderen Seite einen Beitrag zur
Energiesicherheit in Deutschland leisten
können die FDP ist der Auffassung dass
hier sicherlich noch Verbesserungsbedarf
im Laufe der ausschussberatung möglich
ist insgesamt wird in dem
Jahressteuergesetz 2020 sehr viel Gutes
auf den Weg gebracht wir modernisieren
das Steuerrecht wir werden sicherlich
umfangreiche Berichterstatter Beratungen
dazu haben insgesamt ist der Entwurf
jetzt schon sehr gut und ich lade alle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein diesen
Entwurf in den Ausschussberatungen noch
ein Stück weit besser zu machen ich
danke Ihnen
die Mindereinnahmen durch die Maßnahmen
werden im Jahr 2023 auf 3,2 Milliarden
Euro angesetzt im Jahre 2024 auf 3,5
Milliarden Euro Antje Tillmann für die
CDU CSU die finanzpolitische Sprecherin
hat jetzt das Wort liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen liebe Zuhörerinnen liebe
Zuhörer Herr Kollege Meyer ihren ihre
Aufforderung diesen Gesetzentwurf im
Laufe des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens besser
zu machen dem kommen wir gerne nach ich
will gerne ja gleich ein paar Vorschläge
dazu bringen aber tatsächlich haben sie
recht dass dieser Entwurf auch schon
eine ganze Reihe positive Entlastung für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger bringt sie haben
genannt den Ausbildungsfreibetrag Sparer
Pauschbetrag zur richtigen Zeit wo
hoffentlich die Zinsen jetzt wieder
steigen Homeoffice pauschale
Steuerfreistellung des
grundrentenzuschlags sind alles
Maßnahmen die wir mittragen können das
ist eine gute Entlastung der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in dieser Situation da werden
wir zustimmen bei der Photovoltaik
brauchten sie ein bisschen Nachhilfe sie
mussten erst unseren Antrag abschreiben
um dann in diesem Gesetz auch hier
der Steuerfreiheit sowohl in der
Ertragssteuer als auch in der
Umsatzsteuer für 30 kW peakanlagen in
der Photovoltaik auszuweiten wir werden
im Laufe des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens
hinterfragen ob es nicht auch für
Solarthermie machen und genau das können
Sie dann gerne wieder abschreiben und
wir werden dieses Gesetz in dem Punkt
auch noch attraktiver machen
bei der Rentenbesteuerung sich zu loben
ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr weit
hergeholt herr Meier denn die
Rentenbesteuerung ist tatsächlich vom
Verfassungsgericht vorgeschrieben dass
sie den
Sonderausgabenabzug vorziehen ist gut
und richtig aber sie alle haben im
Wahlkampf versprochen dass die zweite
Stufe denn die nachgelagerte Besteuerung
später anfangen zu lassen dass die auch
passiert und genau das steht im
Gesetzentwurf nirgendwo sie halten ihre
Versprechen nicht sie betuppen die
Bürger und dazu kommt dass sie diese 5
Milliarden aus der Rentenbesteuerung
dann auch noch im Entlastungspaket sich
gut schreiben lassen obwohl das mit
Ukraine nur wirklich überhaupt gar
nichts zu tun hat diese
entlastungspakete werden wir nach und
nach hinterfragen
Steuer-ID und das gerade bei der FDP ja
man ja dass sie das nicht angesprochen
haben ist klar denn sie verursachen mit
der Kombination von Steuer-ID und
Bankverbindung erhebliche bürokratische
Kosten 13 zusätzliche Stellen erhebliche
Kosten in der Verwaltung und in der
Wirtschaft und tatsächlich behauptet
dieser Gesetzentwurf dass sie damit
demnächst hochwasserhilfen oder Ukraine
oder corona-hilfen auszahlen könnten
nein Sie können nichts davon gar nichts
denn bei keiner dieser Maßnahmen hätten
sie nur die ID und die Bankverbindung
gebraucht sie verursachen Aktionismus
Kosten Bürokratie ohne dass sie wissen
was sie hinterher mit den Kenntnissen
tatsächlich machen wollen wir wollen ein
Gesamtkonzept bevor wir dem zustimmen
wir wollen nicht das Banken zusätzliche
Kosten haben ohne dass wir hinterher ein
Nutzen davon haben ihnen scheint das
egal zu sein Bürokratieabbau ist bei der
FDP offensichtlich nicht auf der
Tagesordnung
auch bei Riester bei Riester machen Sie
einen ersten minimalen kleinen Schritt
es ist richtig dass sie
Zulageberechtigten riestersparhern mehr
Zeit damit geben
kinderbeträge Kinderzulagen zu
beantragen das ist gut und richtig aber
noch besser wäre die Eltern darauf
hinzuweisen dass sie einen Antrag
stellen müssen damit diese
Kinderzulagen nicht verloren gehen und
diesen Antrag zusätzlich zu fordern
werden wir im Gesetzgebungsverfahren
nachjustieren und ich hoffe dass sie
damit machen es ist auch richtig die
zulagenberechtigung erst zu prüfen und
dann die Zulage auszuzahlen auch das
steht im Gesetzentwurf das ist dabei
wohl schon längst Fakt das wird schon
längst von den zulagenstellen gemacht
was sie aber nicht tun und das ist
gerade bei der dritten Säule
Altersvorsorge nur zwingend sie kümmern
sich nach wie vor nicht über die um die
Attraktivität der
Riester-Verträge 16 Millionen Sparer
müssen seit Jahren mit einer niedrigen
Rendite auskommen und sie haben die
Vorschläge von uns seit einer Legislatur
in einer Legislaturperiode auf dem Tisch
und nichts passiert wir könnten sehr
wohl bei der Beitragsgarantie optional
was machen wir könnten bei der
Auswertung der Förderberechtigten was
tun und wir Kosten könnten ein
kostenarmes Standardprodukt erstellen
nichts davon tun sie das heißt Riester
wird nicht attraktiver tatsächlich
ziehen sich die meisten Anbieter daraus
zurück sie lassen die kleinen Verdienste
mit der Altersvorsorge alleine auch da
werden wir im Gesetzentwurf nachsteuern
gebäude-
herr Meier leider haben sie uns da nur
die eine Hälfte erzählt ja sie erheben
die AfA von zwei auf drei Prozent aber
jeder Steuerrechtler weiß dass im vier
absatz 2 Satz 3 steht dass man die
Nutzungsdauer des Gebäudes auch
nachweisen kann und diese Passage die
von vielen Investoren genutzt wird die
streichen Sie tatsächlich ist es keine
Verbesserung sondern eine
Schlechterstellung von Investoren bei
Gebäuden und das zu einer Zeit wo wir
energetische Sanierung zwingend
bräuchten auch da geht dieser
Gesetzentwurf nicht frei genug wir
werden im Gesetzgebungsverfahren die
anschaffungsnahen Herstellungskosten mit
15% hinterfragen und da haben sie dann
eine Chance dieses Gesetz besser zu
machen
Grunderwerbsteuer auch da kleine
Veränderungen die in die richtige
Richtung gehen aber wir alle haben den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern versprochen dass
es bei der Grunderwerbsteuer einen
Freibetrag geben wird für Familien für
den selbstgenutzten
nichts davon wird tatsächlich
fortgeführt wir werden im weiteren
Verfahren viele Änderungsanträge bringen
zum Beispiel auch für
Kindergeldzahlungen bei Menschen mit
Behinderungen bei Kinderbetreuungskosten
bei der gendergerechten Behandlung von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wir freuen uns
auf die Diskussionen und fordern Sie
gerne auf unseren Anträgen dann auch
zuzustimmen
das Jahressteuergesetz soll im übrigen
die organisatorische Voraussetzung dafür
schaffen dass der Staat künftig jedem
Bürger und jeder Bürgerin direkte
Leistung auszahlen kann dafür soll die
steuerliche Identifikationsnummer mit
der IBAN also der Bankverbindung
verknüpft werden das dürfte sicherlich
noch einige Diskussionen nach sich
ziehen Michael schrodi für die SPD
jedes Jahr mit kleineren aber auch
größeren Veränderungen im Steuerrecht in
den letzten Jahren hatte dieses
Jahressteuergesetz auch klangvolle Namen
wenn ich erinnere an das Jahr 2019
Gesetz zur weiteren steuerlichen
Förderung der Elektromobilität und zur
Änderung weiterer steuerlicher
Vorschriften mit der Änderung der
Hausleitung heißt für der Jahre
Steuergesetz aber es sind weiterhin sehr
gute Inhalte drin ich würde aber sagen
diesmal können es Gesetz auch heißen
Gesetz zur Umsetzung wichtiger Punkte
aus dem Koalitionsvertrag denn viel was
wir dort versprochen haben liefern wir
jetzt schon insgesamt für das Jahr 2023
3,1
Milliarden Euro Entlastungen für den
BürgerInnen Bürger in der Zeit glaube
ich auch ein guter Beitrag zur
Krisenbewältigung meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
ja wir liefern ich kann mir noch
erinnern wie wir in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen darüber
gesprochen haben lieber das Thema
Doppelbesteuerung von Renten die es
jetzt noch nicht gibt aber die wir
natürlich auch ausschließen wollen für
die Zukunft angehen können wir haben uns
jetzt darauf vereinbart sogar auf 2023
jetzt vorzuziehen die volle steuerlich
Abzugsfähigkeit der
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge was
zusätzliche
milliardenentlastungen für die Menschen
bedeutet übrigens die nachgelagerte
Besteuerung werden wir genauso angehen
das sind wir noch auf dem Weg das zu tun
wir machen jetzt einen ersten Schritt
mit milliardenschweren Entlastungen der
nächste wird kommen auch da liefert die
Ampelkoalition
als nächstes
erhöhungsbarer Pauschbetrag auf 1.000
bzw 2000 Euro bei gemeinsam veranlagten
die Erhöhung auch des
ausbildungsfreibetrages aus meiner Sicht
auch etwas was eine wirklich wichtige
Neuerung ist ein Mensch macht ein junger
Mensch macht eine Berufsausbildung was
wir ja wollen er wohnt auswärts er ist
noch kindergeldberechtigt oder die Erde
noch kindergeldberechtigt und diese
Kosten die dadurch verursacht werden
können steuerlich auch geltend gemacht
werden da wird dieser Betrag auch von
924 Euro auf 1200 Euro angehoben auch
dessen Signal wir wollen auch diejenigen
die Berufsausbildung machen die ihren
Kindern auch diesen Weg bieten wollen
ein Stück weit mehr zu entlasten auch
das ein Signal der ampelkollektion das
bei den Menschen dann ankommt die
Homeoffice pauschale haben wir auch
glaube ich Frau Tillmann in der großen
Koalition eine sehr zeitnah und
unbürokratische Lösung gefunden in
dieser Zeit die wir ver zu tun habe
Koalitionsvertrag wir werden sie
evaluieren
und wir werden nach Möglichkeit sich
auch in Fristen das tun wir jetzt wir
tun das jetzt indem wir sogar auch noch
die Höhe anheben auf 1.000 Euro und
gehen gleichzeitig die Frage steuerliche
abzügeshäuslichen Arbeitszimmers an das
zu vereinfachen auch hier liefert die
Ampel wir geben den Menschen die auch zu
Hause arbeiten Sicherheit und auch mehr
an Möglichkeit es sich dafür zu
entscheiden zu Hause zu arbeiten gerade
an der sich veränderten Arbeitswelt auch
hier eine Sache die die Ampel liefert
und die versprochen haben meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren als letztes
und da haben wir durch die Kommission
gaspreisbremse der auch noch mal die
Aktualisierung bekommen und die
Aktualität besser gesagt dieses
Vorhabens mit der gaspreisbremse werden
wir es schaffen Menschen zu entlasten
aber teilweise haben wir auch gesehen
auch in der Pandemie schaffen es nicht
zu zielgenau wie wir das oftmals wollen
weil wir das Instrument nicht haben
jetzt werden wir an der Rechtsgrundlage
schaffen dass wir Direktzahlungen an die
Menschen auf den Weg bringen können dass
wir dieses Instrument der Direktzahlung
auch in Zukunft nutzen können und Frau
Tillmann natürlich wird es dann möglich
sein und das ist dann auch der Wille der
Ampel dass wir das zielgenau machen
machen können Hubertus Haller gesagt es
soll ein soziales Klimagerät sein damit
diejenigen profitieren die entsprechend
auch mehr brauchen und diejenigen nicht
bekommen die das nicht brauchen wir
schaffen jetzt die Rechtsgrundlage dass
wir den Schritt machen das möglich zu
machen Direktzahlungen auf dem Weg zu
bringen von denen wir gesehen haben sie
sind wichtig wir sie werden wichtig in
die Pandemie gewesen das Ziel genau zu
machen wir wollen das hinbekommen die
Rechtsgrundlage wird jetzt geschaffen
ein weiterer wichtiger Schritt für
zukünftige Herausforderungen die wir
jetzt auf den Weg bringen ich freue mich
auf die weitere Beratung zu diesem
Jahressteuergesetz
nächster Redner für die
afd-fraktion Jörn König
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen Liebe Steuerzahler alle
Jahre wieder ein Jahressteuergesetz so
auch dieses Jahr jedes Jahr wird an ein
paar Stellschrauben gedreht hier ein
bisschen geändert dort ein bisschen
gepflegt es ist und bleibt
Flickschusterei ich will Ihnen auch
sagen warum der Gesetzgeber hat
eigentlich verlässliche und verbindliche
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen und eben
nicht ständig alle möglichen Gesetze zu
verschlimmbessern
das ganze ist jedes Mal ein
Arbeitsbeschaffungsprogramm für
Bürokraten vom Ministerium über das
Parlament bis hin zum Steuerberater wann
ging es Belgien wirtschaftlich am besten
als mal 600 Tage keine Regierung
gebildet wurde da hatten die Leute zwei
Jahre lang unverändert stabile Gesetze
und konnten einfach Wirtschaften die
Krönung die Krönung unprofessioneller
und übergriffiger Arbeitsweise erlebten
wir 2019 in Prozess zum Jahre
Steuergesetz 2020 das Gesetz erhielt
damals aus Marketinggründen den Titel
Gesetz zur weiteren steuerlichen
Förderung der Elektromobilität Frau Dr
Giffey mit ihrem guten
an einem lauschigen Dienstagabend im
November gegen 21 Uhr erhielten wir 32
Änderungsanträge der damaligen
Regierungskoalition diese 32 anträge
sollten wir dann nach einer Nachtschicht
morgens früh um 9 Uhr im Finanzausschuss
abstimmen eine Missachtung der
oppositionskollegen sondergleichen und
ein Ausdruck der unprofessionellen
Arbeitsweise hier in diesem Parlament
[Applaus]
wissen Sie was das schöne an einem
solchen Blindflug von ungeplanten
arbeiten ist dass der Misserfolg völlig
überraschend eintritt
kommen wir zu den Stellschrauben im
Jahre Steuergesetz 2022 es sind
insgesamt 16 Stück ich stelle mal ein
paar exemplarisch heraus erstens die
Homos office-pauschale wird infristet
unterhöht das ist positiv viele frei und
Pauschbeträge werden manuell erhöht dies
könnte man zum Beispiel mit einer
Indexierung automatisch und dadurch eben
halt viel besser lösen der Tarif auf
Rädern lässt grüßen den wir schon seit
Ewigkeiten fordern
im Bewertungsgesetz wird die steuerliche
Bewertung von Eigentumswohnungen und
Einfamilienhäusern geändert der
eigentümerverband Haus im Grund
Deutschland schätzt die Erhöhung
zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent ein die
Freibeträge beim Erben werden dadurch
schneller erreicht und dann wird
schneller und höher Erbschaftssteuer
fällig zusammen mit der gerade aktuellen
grundsteuererklärung und einer
Ausarbeitung des wissenschaftlichen
Dienstes des Bundestages mit dem
bezeichnenden Titel Kompetenz des Bundes
zu Erhebung einer einmaligen
Vermögensabgabe in Krisenlagen könnte
man meinen hier wird eine gezielte
Enteignung des Mittelstandes vorbereitet
viertens es soll ein direkter
Zahlungsweg vom Staat zum Bürger für
öffentliche Leistung unter Nutzung der
Steuer-ID geschaffen werden das hört
sich erstmal gut an aber hier werden die
Grundlagen gelegt um große Gruppen des
Volkes dauerhaft von direkten
staatszuwendungen abhängig zu machen
Bürgergeld direkt da Zahlungsweg für
irgendwelche Leistung es scheint immer
weiter in Richtung Umverteilung zu gehen
wie viele Rettungspakete werden davon
ihnen noch kommen die alle die alle von
der fleißigen Mittelschicht bezahlt
werden müssen gehen Sie doch endlich mal
einfach an die Ursachen ran
der arbeitende
der arbeitende netto-steuerzahler egal
ob er Schneider Koslowski oder ötztürk
heißt wird nur noch als maximal
besteuerter geduldeter und demütiger
finanzierungschärfer behandelt das ist
ein Skandal auch der indigene deutsche
für den arbeitende eine Religion ist und
den die Regierung so liebevoll Ackermann
Kartoffeln nennt ja diese Kartoffel
fragt sich warum sie überhaupt noch
arbeiten soll
wenn es sich nicht mehr zu arbeiten
lohnt
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
AFD diesem Jahre Steuergesetz zustimmen
wird vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Jörn König war das für die AFD der
nächste Redner hier zum Jahre
Steuergesetz
2020 Sebastian Schäfer von den
Bündnisgrünen er ist ob man im
Haushaltsausschuss für seine Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren in der akuten Krise wird die
Bundesregierung bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitstellen um für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und unsere
Unternehmen die Folgen der extremen
Preisentwicklungen bei den fossilen
Energien abzufeder
wir nehmen bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro
neue Schulden auf weil in der
Vergangenheit falsche Entscheidungen
getroffen wurden wir können diese nicht
ungeschehen machen und müssen damit
einen Umgang finden
aber diese Koalition betreibt nicht nur
Vergangenheitsbewältigung nicht nur
Krisenpolitik diese Koalition gestaltet
Zukunft und das
und das sehen wir im Jahressteuergesetz
so werden wir ab 2023 für kleinere
Solaranlagen bis 30 Kilowatt
Peakleistung die Umsatzsteuer für
kaufinstallation und Reparatur auf Null
absenken wir haben in diesem Kreis ja
schon gelegentlich über die Umsatzsteuer
und die Komplexität bei den Ausnahmen
gesprochen aber hier geht es darum einen
Investitionsanreiz für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu setzen der
auch volkswirtschaftlich echte Rendite
bringt
Christian Lindner nennt erneuerbare
Energien ja zu Recht freiheitsenergie
gleichzeitig bauen wir damit und das ist
wesentlich bürokratische Hürden ab
vorsteueranmeldungen werden genauso
überflüssig wie die Nutzung der
kleinunternehmerregelungen auch die
Ertragssteuer spielt bei den kleinen
Anlagen keine Rolle mehr das entlastet
BürgerInnen und das entlastet im Fiskus
die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in
den Finanzämtern die Erzeugung von
BürgerInnen und Strom per
Photovoltaikanlage wird einfacher denn
je
ich möchte mich auch herzlich beim
Bundesminister und seinem Haus bedanken
dass er Vorschläge der Länder
Baden-Württemberg und Hessen ins
Jahressteuergesetz aufgenommen hat
Haushalts- und finanzpolitiker:innen
schimpfen ja gerne mal über die Länder
aber dort sitzt ganz viel
verwaltungsexpertise die wir nutzen
können um Prozesse einfacher zu machen
die fortschrittskoalition nimmt
konstruktive Vorschläge ernst wenn es
nicht nur stumpf heißt muss weg
zuletzt hat die gaspreiskommission die
Idee einer sozialen differenzierten
Direktzahlungen als grundsätzlich guten
Mechanismus bezeichnet mit dem Aufbau
eines direkten auszahlungsweges
veröffentliche Leistungen und der
Nutzung der steuerlichen
Identifikationsnummer wird die
fortschrittskoalition damit auch die
Grundlagen für ein Klimagerät auf den
Weg bringen
nicht nur für die gaspreisbremse ist ein
solches Instrument eben notwendig wir
brauchen diesen Mechanismus auch um
Preisanstiege zu kompensieren wenn das
notwendig ist und damit die Akzeptanz
des Marktsystems zu erhöhen herzlichen
Dank
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Janine Wissler
ja und die Parteivorsitzende Janine
Wissler hat jetzt für die Linke
[Applaus]
das Wort
im Jahr Steuergesetz werden viele
Details neu Gere
gelt schade über abschreibungsregelungen
und Freibeträge und das ist in Teilen
auch sinnvoll was aber bleibt das sind
die extremen Ungerechtigkeiten im
Steuersystem und die möchte ich an
dieser Stelle genauer beleuchten wenn
man sich das Steueraufkommen anschaut
dann stellt man fest dass ein großer
Anteil aus Löhnen und Gehältern also aus
Erwerbsarbeit stammt während
leistungsloses Einkommen und Vermögen in
diesem Land kaum besteuert wird wer
nämlich dazu Arbeiten von den Dividenden
seiner geerbten Aktien lebt der zahlt
nach der sogenannten Abgeltungssteuer
pauschal nur 25% Steuern egal ob bei
drei Belegschaftsaktien oder die
unternehmensmehrheit EM milliardenwert
besetzt und das meine Damen und Herren
ist zutiefst ungerecht
die meisten wirklich reichen Menschen in
Deutschland die über Millionen oder
Übergabe Milliardenvermögen verfügen
sind nämlich nicht durch Erwerbsarbeit
reich geworden sondern durch
Kapitalerträge und die müssen endlich
angemessen besteuert werden der Anteil
vermögensbezogener Steuern Deutschland
ist verschwindend gering er liegt bei
nicht mal drei Prozent der
Steueraufkommens während die unteren 40%
der Bevölkerung gar keine Ersparnisse
haben oder sogar Schulden verfügen die
oberen zehn Prozent über 40 über zwei
Drittel des gesamten Vermögens höchste
Zeit meine Damen und Herren für die
wiedererhebung der Vermögenssteuer
auch bei den Erbschaften gibt es
ungerechte steuerlöcher die geschlossen
werden müssen zum Beispiel durch so ein
Gesetz es kommt immer wieder vor dass
jemand ein Unternehmen im Wert von 500
Millionen Euro erbt aber dann keinen
cent-erbschaftssteuer bezahlt und die
Steuergesetze werden ja nicht nur
kreativ genutzt und fantasievoll gedehnt
sondern handfester Steuerbetrug wird
systematisch organisiert wir haben die
Woche schon darüber geredet allein im
cum-ex-skandal wurde die Gesellschaft um
mindestens 32 Milliarden Euro betrogen
32 Milliarden Euro die Schulen und
Krankenhäusern gut hätten gebrauchen
können der tatsächlich ich festgestellte
Steuerbetrug lag im Jahr 2020 bei 1,25
Milliarden Euro zum Vergleich der viel
diskutierte
sozialleistungsbetrug bei 57 Millionen
der Schaden durch Steuerbetrug ist also
22 Mal höher während Menschen die
Grundsicherung beziehen Probleme mit dem
Jobcenter bekommen weil sie Geschenke
von Verwandten bekommen bereichern sich
andere weitgehend ungestört und das hat
auch damit zu tun dass die
Steuerfahndung in Deutschland so
schlecht ausgestattet sind das
regelmäßige Betriebsprüfung überhaupt
nicht möglich sind es ist also nicht das
Sozialsystem das missbraucht wird es ist
das Steuersystem mit seinen
Schlupflöchern und unentdeckten
steuerhinterzieren und daran ändert
dieses Gesetz leider überhaupt nichts
nicht nur Reichtum vererbt sich auch
Armut wer arm ist kann sich so viel
anstrengen wer will der viel gepriesener
Aufstieg durch Bildung und Arbeit
funktioniert nicht deshalb wäre Armut
bekämpfen will der muss Reichtum
umverteilen durch eine Besteuerung
großer Vermögen und hoher Einkommen das
fordern wir als LINKE das fordert auch
die Initiative ich bin armutsbetroffen
die morgen vorm Kanzleramt demonstriert
denn für Armut meine Damen und Herren
müssen sich nicht die Betroffenen
schämen für Armut muss sich eine Politik
schämen die es zulässt vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
parsamari
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja das
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 mag etwas
technisch daherkommen und es ist in der
Tat ein komplexes Gesetz das haben wir
heute ja schon durch verschiedene
liebevolle Detail Betrachtungen gehört
mit einer Vielzahl von Paragrafen und
Bestimmungen die wir hier im Steuerrecht
als Ampel angehen und Modernisieren aber
es ist ein echtes fortschrittsgesetz ein
weiterer Baustein um einen Beitrag zu
aktuellen Krisenlage zu leisten aber
auch um den ampelkoalitionsvertrag
weiter erfolgreich umzusetzen da haben
wir einige schon gemeinsam auf den Weg
gebracht in der Steuerpolitik aber
angesichts von ich habe es mir mal genau
angeschaut 115 Einträgen unter dem
Begriff Steuer im ampelkoalitionsvertrag
haben wir noch einiges vor uns und wenn
augenscheinlich der Redner der AFD keine
Lust hat auf eine handlungsfähige
Regierung in dieser Krisenlage in
Deutschland sage ich ihnen wir sind
außerordentlich froh dass wir regieren
wir haben außerordentlich Lust Steuer
damit auch immer gesellschafts- und
Wirtschaftspolitik in diesem Land zu
gestalten meine Damen und Herren
wir vereinfachen mit diesem Gesetz wie
entbürokratisieren wir schaffen
Rechtssicherheit wir helfen mit
steuerlichen Maßnahmen bei der
Energiewende weg von fossilen
Energieträgern wir fördern den
Wohnungsbau und wir entlasten in einer
Zeit von eingetretenen teuren und
sicherlich im nächsten Jahr noch
andauernder Teuerung so wie ich das
letzte Woche hier gesagt habe diese
Koalition bringt Woche für Woche Gesetze
zu Entlastung und zur Stärkung des
Standorts Deutschland auf den Weg diese
Koalition kann Krisenpolitik das haben
wir inzwischen mit mehreren
entlastungspaketen mit einem Volumen von
über 300 Milliarden Euro bewiesen mit
denen wir das Land sicher durch diesen
Herbst und Winter bringen wollen und wir
machen mit diesem Jahressteuergesetz
genau dort weiter wo wir mit dem vierten
corona-steuer Hilfe gesetzt aufgehört
haben für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer zum Beispiel bei der
Förderung von mobilen und digitalen
Arbeiten jetzt in dieser erneuten Corona
herbstwelle besonders wichtig aber auch
weit darüber hinaus ein Megatrend der
von ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmern als
Angebot und genutzt wird ein Viertel
aller Beschäftigten arbeitet bereits im
Homeoffice doppelt so viele wie vor der
Pandemie und ich bin mir ganz sicher
diese Entwicklung wird sich auch in
postpandemischen Zeiten verstärken und
so weitergehen wir wollen als
SPD-Fraktion des Thema Homeoffice
gesamtgesetzlich weiter auf der Agenda
halten wie Sie wissen aber wir wollen es
jetzt mit diesem Gesetz steuerlich
konkret fördern mit einer verbesserten
homeoffice-pauschale mit verbesserten
Regelungen für das sogenannte häusliche
Arbeitszimmer das ist eine
ampelsteuerpolitik die den
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmern nützt
wir sind eine arbeitnehmerkoalition als
Ampel wir helfen den kleinen sparrern
durch die Erhöhung des
sparer-pauschbetrags wir helfen Familien
bei den Kosten für Studium und
Ausbildung durch die Erhöhung des
ausbildungsfreibetrags wir ziehen den
100%igen Sonderausgabenabzug auf 2023
für Altersvorsorgeaufwendungen vor ja
und wenn sie auch recht haben Frau Thema
dieses Gesetz wäre auch ohne Zeitenwende
ohne Krisenlage kommen aber es hilft
doch das müssen sie doch auch sagen mit
den größeren kleinen Schrauben die wir
hier drehen um ganz konkrete Inflation
entgegenzuwirken
so das ist jetzt mein zweites Gesetz an
dem ich jetzt Berichterstatter
mitarbeiten darf beim ersten ist es sehr
erfolgreich gelungen beim corona-steuer
hilfe-gesetz
hier anwenden noch auf schlaue Ideen
kommen und ein gutes Werk der
Bundesregierung noch besser machen als
Parlament vielen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über das
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 und der nächste
Redner ist oder
Putin vom Finanzausschuss und er hat
heute Geburtstag und die Präsidentin
gratuliert ihm ganz herzlich
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herzerwärmen
was gibt es schöneres als einem
Geburtstag hier in diesem Hohen Haus zu
seinem wichtigen Gesetz zu sprechen aber
das Jahressteuergesetz
ist wieder Geburtstag da kommt
regelmäßig und ich habe schon viele
jahressteuergesetze mittlerweile gesehen
und darf hier heute sagen der Entwurf
für das Jahr 2022 ist tatsächlich nicht
der schlechteste
er ist einiges an Entlastungen drin für
die Steuerzahler wir haben es vorhin
schon gehört Erhöhung Sparer Freibetrag
Erhöhung Homeoffice pauschale Erhöhung
Ausbildungsfreibetrag und es sind ja
auch Vorschläge die wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode immer wieder gemacht
haben konnten sie aber leider mit einem
Finanzminister Olaf Scholz eben nicht
durchsetzen und deswegen an dieser
Stelle erstmal ein ehrliches Lob auch an
Christian
ausrichten ist ehrlich gemeint das sind
gute Sachen drin
aber wir wären natürlich eine schlechte
Opposition hätten wir nicht auch Kritik
und eigene Verbesserungsvorschläge und
ich muss sagen das Eigenlob dass hier
einige der koalitionsredner abgefeiert
haben ist schon stark übertrieben es ist
gut dass ich der Abschreibungssatz bei
Gebäuden im nächsten Jahr von zwei auf
drei Prozent erhöhen soll diese
Forderung hatten wir auch in der Union
schon lange gestellt konnten sie in den
letzten acht Jahren mit dem
Koalitionspartner nie durchsetzen aber
jetzt ist unverständlich warum wir die
Möglichkeit der des Nachweises einer
kürzeren Abschreibungsdauer hier
streichen sollen denn das an die
Tillmann hat es vorhin schon gesagt ist
keine Erleichterung das bedeutet keine
Entlastung für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sondern es bedeutet dass sie
gerade dort wo die Sanierung jetzt so
wichtig wäre im Altbestand wo wir ja die
co2-treiber haben die Sanierung die
energetische Sanierung erschweren es für
Investoren schwieriger machen dort
vernünftig in die Sanierung zu gehen und
das soll es wirklich noch mal nachdenken
ob diese Streichung in dieser Situation
sind zweiter Punkt riesters wurde vorhin
schon angesprochen sie vertun auch hier
eine Chance bei diesem
Jahressteuergesetz die lange
Niedrigzinsphase und der Kombination mit
der Absenkung des
höchstrechnungszinssatzes jetzt zum
ersten Januar diesen Jahres bedeutet im
Prinzip des faktische aus für viele
geförderte Verträge mit 100%iger
Beitragsgarantie kein Anbieter hat in
diesem Jahr entsprechende Produkte
angeboten und viele Altverträge werden
nicht mehr bedient hier entsteht
sehenden Auges tatsächlich eine
Versorgungslücke bei der geförderten
Altersversorgung bei Geringverdienern
und bei Familien die Lösung wäre einfach
wir könnten die
brutto-beitragsgarantie von 100% auf 80%
zum Beispiel absenken mit diesem
Absenkung wäre sowohl im neu wie auch im
Bestandsgeschäft wieder mehr
Möglichkeiten zur Investition es kann
eine renditeträchtigte Produkt
entwickelt werden bei gleichzähliger
Risikoabsicherung aber diese
100-prozentige
Beitragsgarantie ist tatsächlich von
gestern der dritte Punkt den wir an
dieser Stelle anzumerken haben von der
Union ist dass die Einführung eines
neuen Umsatzsteuersatzes von 0 bei der
Lieferung von Solarmodulen an private
photovoltaikbetreiber ja
wie soll ich sagen ordnungspolitisch
schon etwas bizarre ist aber es ist
richtig es ist eine gute Möglichkeit zu
Entbürokratisierung der Bürger oder für
die Bürger aber auch hier muss die Ampel
noch mal nachbessern sie haben vergessen
die Klarstellung dass es auch bei mieten
bei Mietkauf bei
Ratenkauf von Solaranlagen hier zu einem
Anwendung des Null Steuersatzes kommen
muss und da müssen sie einfach noch mal
nachbessern und wenn man das dann
anpackt dann sollte man tatsächlich auch
die
Solarthermieanlagen von dieser Regelung
mit umfasst umfassen denn auch diese
Anlagen produzieren ja mit Energie aus
Sonnenstrom die entsprechende Wärme und
deswegen gehören die auch zum Null
Steuersatz wir sind die konstruktive
Oppositionsfraktion ich glaube das hat
heute auch noch mal jeder erkennen
können wir machen konkrete Vorschläge
Verbesserungsvorschläge
wir erwarten gespannt wir ja auch
deswegen natürlich aber wir sind ja auch
sonst immer konstruktiv und wir erwarten
jetzt mit Spannung die Vorschläge auf
das Bundesrates wo ja auch noch mal
einiges aus den Ländern kommen wird und
ich freue mich jedenfalls auf die
weiteren Beratungen auf die Verbesserung
hoffentlich Verbesserung in diesem
Gesetz in diesem Sinne gehen wir es an
Olaf guting heute wird er 52 Jahre alt
und das Hohe Haus hat eben gratuliert
der Applaus allerdings am Schluss kam
nur von seiner eigenen Fraktion Sascha
Müller jetzt ob man den Finanzausschuss
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen erstmals liegt die
fortschrittskoalition ein
Jahressteuergesetz vor und setzt damit
im Steuerrecht eine ganze Reihe von
Regelungen um die im Koalitionsvertrag
verankert worden sind dazu gehört
beispielsweise die Vermeidung der
Doppelbesteuerung der Renten und durch
das Vorziehen der vollständigen
steuerlichen Absetzbarkeit von
Aufwendung für die Altersvorsorge und
damit sorgen wir eben auch für weitere
Entlastungen oder auch die Entfristung
der homeoffice-pauschale mit der wir
Veränderungen in der arbeitsweltrechnung
tragen
entscheidere entscheidende
Verbesserungen und Erleichterungen
nehmen wir bei der Photovoltaik vor und
sorgen damit für einen weiteren Push für
die Energiewende und vieles andere mehr
das zeigt entgegen anderslautenden auch
hier im Haus mit unter artikulierten
Gerüchten funktioniert die Ampel gut sie
funktioniert
wir bringen wir bringen nicht nur drei
entlastungspakete im Wert von 95
Milliarden Euro und ein Abwehrschirm von
200 Milliarden Euro auf den Weg sondern
wir sicher nicht nur unsere
Energieversorgung trotz des Ausbleibens
der Gaslieferung aus Russland wir
bekämpfen nicht nur die Inflation mit
gaspreisbremse und strompreisdeckel und
wir arbeiten gleichzeitig an einer
sicherungssäuren Energieversorgung auf
Basis von erneuerbaren Energien nein wir
modernisieren auch das Steuerrecht und
bringen mit dem auszahlungsmechanismus
für künftige Entlastung eine kleine
Revolution auf den Weg erstmals
erstmals wird der Staat in die Lage
versetzt Geldzahlungen an alle
BürgerInnen vorzunehmen und das eben
ohne bürokratische Antragsverfahren
mussten wir bei der
energiepreisspauschale noch den Umweg
über die Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber gehen so kann künftig der
Staat etwa ein klimagergeld direkt auf
das mit der Steuer-ID verknüpfte
Bankkonto überweisen ja dieses Vorhaben
ist zunächst ein Kraftakt aber eine
lohnender Kraftakt und wir sollten das
so zügig wie möglich angehen auch die
Länder unterstützend diesen Weg und
haben sich gerade erst noch eine
schnelle Umsetzung gewünscht und das ist
auch unser Wunsch
eine weitere
eine weitere Neuerung ist dass wir die
lineare Abschreibung neuer Gebäude in
diesem Gesetzentwurf von jährlich zwei
Prozent auf 3% anheben es kommt dem
Schaffen neuen Wohnraum bis zur gute und
für uns Grüne würde es noch besser wenn
wir das auch gezielt mit der Schaffung
von energetisch effizientem Wohnraum
verbinden können sie sehen es gibt eine
ganze Reihe von guten Punkten in diesem
Gesetzentwurf und ich will nicht
ausschließen dass wir nicht noch den
einen oder anderen guten Punkt im
weiteren parlamentarischen Verfahren
ergänzen werden insofern freue ich mich
auf die weitere Erörterung in den
berichterstattergesprächen in der
anstehenden Anhörung und dem Ausschuss
und danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion Tim
Klüssendorf
und Tim klüsendorf ist der letzte Redner
zum Jahressteuergesetz 2022 das dann
weiter verwiesen wird in die Ausschüsse
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich habe mich ja sehr gefreut
über so viel Kong Konstruktivität der
cdu/csu-fraktion nachdem wir gestern in
der cumex-debatte doch die ein oder
andere Auseinandersetzung hatten so
stelle ich mir das vorder freue ich mich
dass meine Rede von gestern so schnell
Wirkung erzielt hat vielen Dank dafür
ich möchte heute aber meine Redezeit
nutzen um zum Thema PV noch mal
ausführlich zu sprechen weil das ja doch
auf jeden Fall riesiger Schritt in
Richtung weniger Bürokratie und auch in
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
bedeutet wir haben uns im
Koalitionsvertrag in ampelregierung
darauf festgelegt dass wir von 60
Gigawatt auf 200 Gigawatt bis 2030
ausbauen wollen heute das
Jahressteuergesetz ist tatsächlich ein
wesentlicher Schritt dahin wir
entbürokratisieren wir erleichtern und
ich will mal um das deutlich zu machen
einmal kurz darstellen wie eigentlich
der Weg ist wenn ich jetzt eine Familie
habe wenn ich auf mein Einfamilienhaus
eine PV-Anlage setzen will was ich dann
alles zu beachten habe es fängt
natürlich damit an dass sich über die
baurechtlichen Vorschriften erkundigen
muss Fördermittel beantragen bewilligen
lassen das sind alles Themen die uns
sozusagen im Steuerprozess gar nichts
angehen anlagenprotokoll vom
Handwerksbetrieb Daten im Netzbetreiber
melden bei der Bundesnetzagentur ins
Markt
stammdatenregister eintragen lassen die
Anlage versichern Zähler anschaffen ist
übrigens gar nicht trivial weil die
Stadtwerke im Moment riesige Probleme
haben die ganzen Zähler zu beschaffen
Netzbetreiber ansprechen wegen der
Einspeisevergütung und bei größeren
Anlagen über 10 kW muss ich auch noch
ein Gewerbe anmelden das ist erstmal der
erste Teil da bin ich noch gar nicht
beim steuerlichen Teil jetzt kommt der
steuerlicher teil und die
Verbraucherzentrale sagt bitte klären
Sie vorher die steuerrechtlichen Themen
weil sie werden sonst auf gar keinen
Fall am Ende zum Erfolg kommen
Umsatzsteuer einfacher Weg
Kleinunternehmerregelung das heißt ich
habe Umsätze weniger als 22.000 Euro im
ersten Jahr 50.000 Euro im Folgejahr das
ist ganz gut weil man ein wenig
Bürokratie hat der Nachteil ist ich kann
die Umsatzsteuer nicht als Vorsteuer
erstatten lassen das heißt die
Anschaffungskosten sind sozusagen höher
hat also ein Anreiz doch Umsatzsteuer an
was passiert aber wenn ich Umsatzsteuer
anmelde ich kann mir eigentlich ein Büro
im Finanzamt einrichten weil ich
monatlich vorsteueranmeldungen schon als
normale Familie leisten muss bei
Nachrüstung mit batteriespeichern kommt
es sogar dazu dass ich meine Batterie
noch mal einzeln anmelden muss Anlage
die normale solarenergieanlage die
Batterieanlage werden dann noch mal
einzeln beim Finanzamt gemeldet man
merkt also okay das ist schon eine Menge
an Bürokratie ich bin jetzt aber noch
nicht bei der Einkommensteuer die
Einkommensteuer kommt auch noch oben
drauf maximal 10 kW darf ich haben dann
ist es Liebhaberei die durchschnittliche
solarenergieanlage die PV-Anlage hat
aber 7 bis 15 7 bis 15 ist natürlich für
ein Grenzwert bei 10 relativ ungünstig
das heißt auch da eine große Problematik
die wir in diesem Gesetz aufdecken ohne
Vereinfachungsregelung habe ich also
auch in der Einkommensteuer noch eine
Menge Bürokratie zu erledigen und
deswegen jetzt ganz wichtig was macht
dieses Jahressteuergesetz in den letzten
20 Sekunden Einkommenssteuer wir setzen
den Grenzwert hoch auf 30 kW extrem
wichtig um steuerfrei zu sein und die
Liebhaberei auszu Umsatzsteuer wir
führen den notsteuersatz ein sodass die
kleine unternehmerregelungen ohne
finanzielle Nachteile anzuwenden ist und
von allen genutzt werden kann und einen
dritten Punkt noch die
Lohnsteuerhilfevereine dürfen künftig
auch beraten das dürfen sie im Moment
jetzt nicht das ist ein wirklich ganz
wesentlicher Schritt der
Entbürokratisierung und ich freue mich
dass wir heute mit diesem Gesetz einen
ganzen Schritt vorangehen
sagt Tim küssendorf Mindereinnahmen für
den Staat in diesem in einem kommenden
Jahr 3,2 Milliarden 3,5 Milliarden im
Jahr 2024 in das Jahressteuergesetz 2022
wird jetzt weiter in den Ausschüssen
beraten bevor es dann hier in 2 und 3
Lesung wieder aufgerufen wird schauen
wir nach vorne es geht jetzt um einen
Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion Fach- und
Arbeitskräfte mit zielgerichteten
Maßnahme im Inland gewinnen so heißt der
Antrag dort geht es unter anderem darum
das Fachkräftepotenzial im Inland
auszuschöpfen die hohe
Schulabbrecherquote soll mit
verschiedenen Maßnahmen verändert werden
und weiter fordert die cdu/csu eine
Reform des Arbeitszeitgesetzes die eine
wöchentliche Stadt tägliche
Höchstarbeitszeit im Rahmen flexibler
Arbeitszeitmodelle
ermöglicht und der erste Redner wird
gleich aufgerufen wenn hier ein bisschen
mehr Ruhe reingekommen ist denn das
kennen sie zwischen den verschiedenen
Punkten kommen die für diesen Punkt hier
reden und vorgesehen sind andere gehen
wieder unter anderem sehen wir gerade
Arbeitsminister Hubertus Heil eilt
herbei bei diesem Punkt und jetzt der
erste Redner kommt von der cdu/csu Klaus
Wiener
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Fachkräftemangel droht zu einer massiven
Wachstumsbremse für die deutsche
Wirtschaft zu werden schätzungen gehen
davon aus dass unser Wachstumspotenzial
auch aufgrund des Fachkräftemangels in
den nächsten Jahren deutlich schrumpfen
wird damit ist der Fachkräftemangel
neben der Energieversorgung eine der
größten wirtschaftlichen
Herausforderungen unserer Tage wenn das
Produktionspotenzial nur noch auf 0,7
Prozent taxiert wird das kann man so
auch nachlesen in der jüngsten
Gemeinschaftsdiagnose
dann hört sich das zunächst vielleicht
mal harmlos an das ist es aber nicht
denn über einen Zeitraum von zehn Jahren
ist der Verlust den man bekommt
gegenüber einer Welt mit 1,5% Wachstum
das sind 320 Milliarden Euro ich habe
das auch mal in eine Rechnungseinheit
dass sie die alle jetzt ganz gut kennen
das sind 1,5 doppelwumms also viel Geld
versuche das Fachkräftepotenzial Problem
zu lindern gibt es ja schon länger ich
erinnere zum Beispiel an das Fachkräfte
Zuwanderungsgesetz obwohl in der Sache
ordentlich gemacht funktioniert das mit
der Zuwanderung von Fachkräften immer
noch nicht so richtig hier in
Deutschland Menschen die zu uns kommen
sind oftmals auch wieder weg tatsächlich
ist es so dass jeder zweite der nach
Deutschland einwandert dann auch wieder
Deutschland verlässt ein ernüchternder
Befund wie ich finde und ich kann Ihnen
auch sagen woran das liegt zumindest zu
einem ganz wesentlichen Teil ich habe
selbst mal fünf Jahre im Ausland gelebt
und mit vielen Menschen mit guter
Ausbildung und auch hoher
internationaler Mobilität gesprochen was
wollen diese Menschen wenn sie migrieren
naja ganz einfach sie wollen Geld
verdienen weil sie sich eine Existenz
aufbauen wollen wenn sie aber in
Deutschland ihre erste Gehaltsabrechnung
bekommen dann sind sie geschockt 40 bis
50 Prozent gehen locker weg bei Ledigen
der Steuerklasse 1
der Selbstbehalt des Einkommens gerade
noch bei 35 Prozent das können sie jedes
Jahr beim Bund der Steuerzahler
nachlesen aber selbst da trotz dieser
hohen Belastung wollen sie ja noch
draufsetzen satteln obwohl in
Deutschland doch schon Fachkräfte
oftmals den Spitzensteuersatz Zahlen so
etwas spricht sich schnell rum und weil
es in nahezu einen anderen Ländern mit
denen wir um gute Leute konkurrieren
nicht so ist sind viele dann auch
schnell wieder weg ein weiteres Problem
über das sie auch gestern schon intensiv
debattiert wurde ist ihr
Paradigmenwechsel in der
Einwanderungspolitik mit dem Spurwechsel
machen sie aus illegale Einwanderung per
Gesetzesbeschluss einfach mal so legale
Einwanderung das allein finde ich aus
rechtsstaatlicher Sicht schon
bemerkenswert noch schlimmer aber ist
noch viel schlimmer aber ist
dass sie gar nicht genau hinsehen damit
was die Menschen die zu uns kommen
wirklich können ich glaube viele von
ihnen haben überhaupt gar keine
Vorstellung davon was
zerspanungstechniker Mechatroniker oder
Heizungsbauer heute so können müssen
haben Sie schon mal von Computer
gesteuerten dreh- und Fräsmaschinen
gehört damit produktiv umzugehen damit
produktiv umzugehen dass lernt man nicht
mal so nebenbei in einem Schnellkurs und
das Beherrschen zu beherrschen brauchen
sie eine gute
Schulausbildung und eine drei bis
dreieinhalbjährige Berufsausbildung und
selbst dann stehen sie noch ganz am
Anfang ihres Könnens ich kann das so ein
bisschen beurteilen weil ich vor meinem
Studium der Volkswirtschaft auch meine
Ausbildung zum Energieanlagen
Elektroniker gemacht habe nein mit dem
Spurwechsel werden sie den
Fachkräftemangel nicht bekämpfen das ist
eine
Illusion
in den kommenden 15 Jahren und diese
Zahlen muss man sich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen in den kommenden 15
Jahren werden knapp 13 Millionen
Babyboomer in Rente gehen das heißt der
Fachkräftemangel der heute schon ein
großes Problem ist droht zu einem noch
viel größeren zu werden deshalb müssen
auch in dieser Frage wirklich alle
Optionen auf den Tisch und dazu gehört
zu allererst natürlich auch dass wir die
im Inland vorhandenen Potenziale heben
denn da ist doch einiges zu heben in
unserem Antrag haben wir formuliert was
zu tun ist ich nenne hier nur einige
Punkte zum einen muss die Zahl der
Schulabbrecher verringert werden 2020
haben rund 45.000 Schülerinnen und
Schüler die Schule ohne Abschluss
verlassen das zu viel deshalb muss die
Bundesregierung mit den Ländern sprechen
und daraufhin wirken dass die
Berufsorientierung in den Schulen
verbessert wird auch müssen schulpläne
so ausgestaltet werden dass unsere
Schülerinnen und Schüler fit für den
Berufsalltag auch Fliesenleger übrigens
müssen den Satz des Pythagoras kennen
wir müssen auch mehr junge Menschen für
die Handwerksberufe begeistern das gilt
gerade auch für Mädchen ich habe vor ein
paar Monaten die Lossprechung also die
Rede bei der Lossprechung gemacht
Elektroniker bei mir im Wahlkreis von
den insgesamt 50 neuen Gesellen weil
gerade mal eine junge Dame dabei ich
bleibe auch hier ist ein großer Hebel
hinsichtlich der finanziellen
Ausstattung ist es immer noch so dass
die berufliche Bildung deutlich weniger
unterstützt wird als die akademische ich
gebe nur ein Beispiel die Kosten der
überbetrieblichen Ausbildung werden
immer noch zu einem großen Teil von den
Unternehmen selbst getragen und das
trifft dann gerade die kleinen und die
mittleren Unternehmen die hier zur Kasse
gebeten werden ich glaube niemand käme
auf die Idee die akademische Ausbildung
den Großunternehmen in Rechnung zu
stellen und
und
da ich schon die akademische Ausbildung
angesprochen habe wir müssen natürlich
auch Studierende zu Beginn des Studiums
viel enger durch gezielte Programme
begleiten nur so können wir
Studienabbrecher und
studienabbrecherinnen schneller
auffangen mit einer Abbruchquote von 27
Prozent im Jahr 2018 ist auch hier das
Potenzial erheblich wir müssen auch die
Erfahrung der älteren Generation länger
nutzen dazu gehören flexible
Arbeitszeitmodelle und einen flexibles
renteneintrittsaltern klar nicht jeder
kann jeden Job über das 67 lebensjahr
hinaus machen bei vielen Tätigkeiten
geht das aber und viele Menschen wollen
das auch und damit würden wir übrigens
auch einen der größten sozialpolitischen
Fehler der letzten Legislaturperiode
heilen nämlich die Rente mit 63
es gibt viele Möglichkeiten das
Arbeitskräfte Angebot und Potenzial in
Deutschland zu verbessern von 83
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland sind
aktuell nur 34 Millionen
sozialversicherungspflichtig beschäftigt
mit Blick auf die sozialen
Sicherungssysteme ist es unabdingbar
dass wir diese Zahl die er in den Jahren
der CDU-Regierung schon deutlich
gestiegen ist dass wir diese Zahl weiter
nach oben bringen dafür müssen sich aber
von Linken Fantasien wie den Bürgergeld
verabschieden denn damit torpedieren sie
jegliche Anreize zur Arbeitsaufnahme ich
jedenfalls Kriege aus meinem Wahlkreis
nicht aus meinen Aral Kreis viele Briefe
von frustrierten Leuten die sagen ich
gehe arbeiten für ein Geld das die
anderen Leuten die Regierung die Ampel
so zur Verfügung stellen will das ist
ein Schlag ins Gesicht das ist ein
Schlag ins Gesicht aldera die unserem
Land hart arbeiten müssen und dafür die
erforderlichen Steuern aufbringen
Handlungsmöglichkeiten haben wir unserem
Antrag etliche aufgezeigt sie werden gut
beraten diese Vorschläge aufzugreifen
statt einen drängendes
gesellschaftliches und auch
wirtschaftliches Problem mit sachfremden
Themen wie dem Spurwechsel oder der wie
nennen sie das
mehrfachstaatsangehörigkeit zu
vermischen vielen Dank
eine Zahl die in diese Debatte passt
jedes Jahr verlassen etwa 45.000
Jugendliche die Schule ohne einen
Abschluss erreicht zu haben das sind an
die sieben Prozent eines Jahrgangs und
deutlich mehr als vor zehn Jahren
Natalie public jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verehrte Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer es
ist wirklich bemerkenswert welche Themen
die cdu/csu-fraktion nun in der
Opposition für sich entdeckt hat Themen
um diese sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten
nicht wirklich gekümmert haben
wir förder
ung all demokratischer Politik und wir
wollen jeden Menschen die bestmöglichen
Chancen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt bieten das
haben wir unter anderem mit dem
qualifizierungschancengesetz in der
letzten Legislaturperiode getan und das
tun wir auch mit der Reform des
Bürgergelds mit dem aus- und
Weiterbildungsgesetz unter
fachkräftestrategie in diesem Jahr
erst am Mittwoch hat das Bundeskabinett
die fachkräftestrategie beschlossen und
dabei fünf wesentliche Stellschrauben
zur
Fachkräftegewinnung definiert
wir wollen die berufliche und die duale
Ausbildung stärken um den
fachkräftemachwuchs in Deutschland zu
sichern zweitens wir wollen das
Beschäftigte von heute eine Chance auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt von morgen haben und
dafür fördern wir gezielte Weiterbildung
und Qualifizierung
wir wollen das inländische
Arbeitspotenzial und die
Erwerbsbeteiligung erhöhen das
beinhaltet unter anderem die Förderung
von Vollzeitbeschäftigung bei Frauen
oder mehr Inklusion von Menschen mit
Behinderung auf dem Arbeitsmarkt wir
wollen die Verbesserung der
Arbeitsqualität und der Arbeitskultur
damit Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
lange gesund erwerbsfähig bleiben und
wir wollen mit einem modernen
Einwanderungsrecht Fachkräften Zugang zu
unserem Arbeitsmarkt eröffnet und genau
das hat die Union in den letzten Jahren
blockiert
um dem Fachkräftemangel entgegen zu
wirken braucht es also einen Mix an
unterschiedlichen Maßnahmen und zwei
möchte ich dabei besonders hervorheben
wir modernisieren und stärken die duale
Ausbildung denn für unser Zusammenleben
sind Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker
Bäckerinnen und Becker Verkäuferinnen
Erzieherinnen produzieren und das
Pflegepersonal essentiell unser Land
lebt von den vielen kleinen und
mittelständischen Betrieben und ihre
Fachkräften und diese Fachkräfte müssen
eben auch ausgebildet werden
vor wenigen Tagen informierte die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit darüber dass in
diesem Herbst noch 75.000 junge Menschen
die eine Ausbildung machen wollen kein
Ausbildungsplatz gefunden haben
2,16 Millionen junge Menschen haben
deutschlandweit keinen Berufsabschluss
und wir können es uns als Gesellschaft
einfach nicht leisten das Potenzial
dieser junge Menschen zu vergeuden
wir wollen die Lehrstellen Suchenden in
die offenen Lehrstellen bringen dazu
erhöhen wir die ausbildungsmobilität in
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern bauen wir
die jugendberufsagenturen aus und
stärken die Berufsberatung und
Berufsorientierung und gleichzeitig
führen wir auch eine Ausbildungsgarantie
ein die allen Jugendlichen den Zugang zu
einer vollqualifizierten
Berufsausbildung ermöglicht
in meinem Wahlkreis dem im hessischen
Karben gibt es das Berufsbildungswerk
Südhessen dort werden Jugendliche mit
besonderem Förderbedarf in
Zusammenarbeit mit den örtlichen
Betrieben und einem hohen Praxisbezug in
31 verschiedenen Ausbildungsberufen
ausgebildet die Vermittlungsquote beim
bbw Südhessen liegt bei über 70 Prozent
und Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich kriege
bis heute Gänsehaut wenn ich an die
Abschlussfeier beim bbw Südhessen
zurückdenke dort standen junge Menschen
an die oft niemand in unserer
Gesellschaft geglaubt haben auf der
Bühne mit ihren Zeugnissen in der Hand
sie waren voll motiviert und Vorfreude
auf das Berufsleben weil ihnen eine
Chance gegeben wurde und genau darum
geht das Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass junge
Menschen mit unserem Land auf der
Strecke bleiben
unsere Arbeitswelt verändert sich neue
Berufsbilder entstehen und andere werden
ersetzt oder fallen Perspektive Weg als
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion treten wir dafür
ein dass aus technologischer Innovation
sozialer Fortschritt wird für
langfristige Chancen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt ist dabei die Weiterbildung
und Qualifizierung essentiell wir werden
Deutschland zu einer
weiterbildungsrepublik weiterentwickeln
und das tun wir indem wir zielgerichtete
Qualifizierung fördern indem wir die
Zusammenarbeit der Bundestag Agentur für
Arbeit und die den Akteurinnen Doktoren
vor Ort stärken und die individuelle
Beratung für die Beschäftigten fördern
das tun wir aber auch indem wir eine
Bildungszeit einführen mit der
beschäftigte sich während des
Erwerbslebens weiterbilden können weil
Bildung eben Zeit braucht und
Weiterbildung nicht an finanziellen
Ressourcen scheitern darf
und das tun wir auch mit dem
qualifizierungsgeld indem wir
unternehmen die von Strukturwandel
betroffen sind dabei unterstützen ihre
Fachkräfte weiter zu qualifizieren und
sie trotz neuer Anforderungen im
Unternehmen zu halten und ihnen aber
auch neue Perspektiven auf dem
regionalen Arbeitsmarkt zu ermöglichen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Weg vom
Produktionshelfer zum Maschinenführer
von der Kassiererin zu Erzieherin vom
Elektriker zum Solaranlagen Installateur
das soll keine Seltenheit in unserem
Land sein sondern gelebte Realität und
genau dafür sorgt die Ampelkoalition
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Ausnahme
nächste Rednerin für die afd-fraktion es
geht hier um einen Antrag der
cocsu-fraktion Gewinnung von Fach und
Arbeitskräften im Inland und für die AFD
hat jetzt Gerrit Huy das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ein rohstoffarmes Land wie Deutschland
braucht kluge Köpfe und geschickte Hände
da halten wir es für eine gute Sache
dass jetzt endlich einmal einen Antrag
vorgelegt wird in dem Arbeitskräfte
facharbeitskräfte im Inland gewonnen
werden sollen
im Bereich der Schlüsseltechnologien
gibt es einen erheblichen Bedarf an hoch
qualifizierten Fachkräften welche späte
Erkenntnis offenbar musste die Union
dafür erst einmal in die Opposition
wechseln und dass sie jetzt die
Regierung auffordert gemeinsam mit den
Ländern einen Pakt zu Reduzierung der
hohen Schulabbrecherquote zu schließen
wird schon ein wenig grotesk sie stellen
doch in sechs Bundesländern der
Ministerpräsidenten da hätten sie doch
längst mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen
können denn neu sind diese Probleme
nicht neben der besonders
immigrantischen Milieus viel zu hohen
Schulabbrecherquote sind auch die
Schulleistungen inzwischen unterirdisch
bereits Drittklässler liegen anderthalb
Jahre in ihren Leistungen zurück jeder
fünfte Neuntklässler kann Texte nicht
Sinn also Sinn erklären kann den Sinn
von Texte nicht verstehen
und in der Mathematik sind wir im Länder
vergleicht auf Platz 33 gelandet einen
Platz vor alt Bahnen wir müssen uns also
nicht wundern wenn da am Ende zu wenig
Fachkräfte herauskommen das erste was
deswegen passieren muss ist mehr Lehrer
einzustellen der Beruf macht aber den
meisten Lehrern keinen Spaß mehr unsere
Lehrer haben einfach genug von der
ständigen jahrelang Überforderung mit
Vielsprachigkeit Inklusion großen
Klassen und respektlosen Schülern hier
muss die Politik endlich ran
und es braucht auch mehr Geld in der
Bildung gerade auch in der
Grundschulbildung wir hängen dahinter
und vielen Ländern hinterher im
unionsantrag gibt es noch eine lange
Liste anderer Maßnahmen die
grundsätzlich richtig sind aber sehr
wenig konkret so dass es wenig Sinn
macht sie jetzt zu kommentieren aber
immerhin die Union ahnt inzwischen wohl
das Einwanderung unsere Probleme nicht
lösen wird weil wir einfach zu
unattraktiv sind um wirkliche Fachkräfte
anzuziehen unsere Nettolöhne für
Hochqualifizierte liegen nur im hinteren
Drittel aller OECD-Länder wegen unserer
abenteuerlich hohen Steuern Abgabenlast
und das medienvermögen junger Leute
zwischen 16 und 34 Jahren liegt bei
knapp zehntausend Euro fast überall in
der EU haben junge Leute mehr in Polen
etwa viermal so viel in Belgien sechs
Mal so viel und den Luxemburg fast 14
Mal so viel warum sollten qualifizierte
junge Menschen nach Deutschland kommen
und damit komme ich zu einem wichtigen
Punkt in die Union leider vergessen hat
die inzwischen extrem
angewachsene Auswanderung sorry
hochqualifizierter deutscher die merken
nämlich inzwischen auch dass in diesem
Land nicht mehr voran kommen können das
haben jüngere Auswanderer letzten Monat
im Magazin Cicero gesagt und sie haben
noch weitere Gründe genannt erstens ein
rigides gesellschaftliches Klima
zweitens politische übergriffigkeiten
bis in die Ängste Privatsphäre und
drittens Beibehaltung der
preistreibenden Energiewende trotz
Inflation
trotz Strom und gasknappheit die frühere
Gewissheit in einem der freiesten Länder
der Welt zu leben haben diese junge
Menschen verloren oft wollen sie einfach
nur noch weg
Lea wird es deswegen bei uns nicht denn
für unqualifizierte Einwanderer taugen
wir bekanntlich noch durchaus aber meine
Damen und Herren der Regierungsparteien
die unqualifizierten kommen die
qualifizierten gehen ist es wirklich das
was Sie wollen danke
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Andreas Aurich
der stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzende die Grünen hier
heute ganz normal anwesend sie werden
nachher wahrscheinlich weiterfahren nach
Bonn da ist ja der Parteitag der Grünen
den wir bei Phoenix live übertragen
werden heute Abend und da geht es gleich
interessant bis Mitternacht um die
akw-frage also Andreas Aurich jetzt hier
im Parlament mit der Post unterwegs und
habe mir deren Arbeit angeschaut und ich
kann Ihnen sagen dass die postbotinnen
und Postboten in meinem Wahlkreis in
Neukölln mittlerweile extra Straßen
laufen müssen weil es zu wenig Menschen
gibt die dort die Arbeit machen wollen
im Juli 2022 fehlten in fast der Hälfte
aller vom Ifo-Institut befragten
Unternehmen Arbeitskräfte das sind
zentrales Problem mit dem wir umgehen
müssen und deswegen kommt die
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
genau zur richtigen Zeit
wir haben begonnen Deutschland zur
weiterbildungsrepublik zu machen es ist
auch was was sie in den letzten 16
Jahren gerne mal hätten angehen können
und ein zentraler Baustein dafür ist
dass wir mit dem Bürgergeld Hartz IV
überwinden wir richten die
Grundsicherung aus auf Weiterbildung wir
richten sie aus darauf dass Menschen
Chancen kriegen und Zukunft entwickeln
können der Vorrang der Vermittlungen den
nächst schlechtesten Job der wird
abgeschafft dafür gehen wir darauf ein
dass Menschen langfristig qualifiziert
werden dass Menschen langfristig Chancen
kriegen auch Aufstiegschancen kriegen
und genau darum geht es in diesem Gesetz
auch mit Anreizen 150 Euro die man
kriegt wenn man in einen neuen Beruf
hineingeht das sind alles Möglichkeiten
Menschen auf den Weg zu schicken und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir das
Bürgergeld genauso ausgestalten und
jetzt gemeinsam auf den Weg bringen
und Sie liebe Union sie hatten sie
hatten eine Chance und sie reden immer
darüber dass ihnen die Menschen die
arbeiten besonders wichtig sein sie
hatten eine Chance in den letzten
Monaten das unter Beweis zu stellen das
war der Moment als es hier im Plenum um
den Mindestlohn gegangen ist und was
haben sie gemacht sie haben sich der
Zustimmung verweigert sie haben genau an
der Stelle das getan was nicht relevant
wäre jetzt um Menschen zu helfen in
diesen Niedriglohnsektoren Arbeiten
ihnen geht es nicht darum tatsächlich
Arbeit attraktiv zu machen ihnen geht es
nicht darum dass Menschen mehr kriegen
wenn sie im Niedriglohnsektor sind ihnen
geht es einzig und allein um ihren
falschen Populismus und den hier in die
Welt zu wollen das ist das das ist das
was sie wollen und das haben Sie an
dieser Stelle mehr als ausreichend
bewiesen
ein zweiter Punkt zweiter Punkt ist die
Frage Einwanderung und natürlich
brauchen wir Zuwanderung in Deutschland
ich bin froh dass wir Menschen die vor
Putins Krieg geflohen sind eine
Arbeitserlaubnis gegeben haben das
schnell getan haben und dass wir sie
gleichzeitig mit den Jobcentern
zusammengebracht haben das heißt nämlich
dass die Unterstützung kriegen dass die
Informationen kriegen dass sie
Weiterbildung kriegen und das was sie
getan hätten wäre diesen Menschen die
Arbeitserlaubnis zu verweigern es wäre
gewesen dass sie den historischen Fehler
den sie diesem Land über Jahrzehnte
aufgezwungen haben dass sie den
wiedergemacht hätten sie werden in die
gleiche alte Falle getappt es ist
richtig dass diese Menschen arbeiten
können ist es richtig dass dieses tun
weil sie etwas beizutragen haben und ich
weiß dass es ihnen auch an dieser Stelle
schwer fällt Mainz 21 Jahrhundert zu
kommen und dass sie den Bezug zur
deutschen Wirtschaft zu
Familienunternehmen zu Industrie völlig
verloren haben gehen sie da mal hin die
brauchen diese Arbeitskräfte ich habe
nur eine Bitte ich habe nur eine bitte
machen sie ihre ideologischen Spielchen
nicht zu Lasten der Unternehmen die
genau diese Leute brauchen die darauf
warten dass die anfangen zu arbeiten sie
halten die Leute weg die Grenzen Leute
aus vom Arbeitsmarkt dass sie ihre
Politik und die ist nicht zukunftsfähig
deswegen haben sie auch keinen Kontakt
an der Stelle zur Wirtschaft deswegen
kann man diesen Punkten von ihnen
einfach keinerlei Glaubwürdigkeit
schenken so ein ein Punkt am Ende noch
eine Gruppe taucht nämlich fast gar
nicht auf und jetzt müssen sie sehr sehr
stark sein jetzt sage ich Ihnen was was
sie was was sie noch nicht mal zu denken
wagen um mit dem Fachkräftemangel
umzugehen brauchen wir eine
feministische Wirtschaftspolitik es muss
endlich zum Schluss sein damit dass wir
den gender pay-gape haben es muss
endlich Schluss sein damit dass wir ein
kehrgab haben es muss endlich Schluss
sein mit einem Steuersystem das Frauen
dezidiert zu Hause hält das was sie über
Jahre programmiert haben all das muss
weg deswegen ist es gut dass wir als
Koalition diese Fragen angehende neue
Politik machen und die
fachkräftestrategie kommt zur rechten
Zeit wir setzen das um und gehen die
Fragen an vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Pascal Meiser
Sprecher für Gewerkschaftspolitik und
dienstleistungspolitik der Linksfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und
Herren es ist sehr aufregend hier ich
halte die Zeit noch mal kurz an vielen
Dank damit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen damit der
Redner hier vorne auch seine volle
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen sie dürfen noch
mal beginnen vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren ist
in der Tat höchste Zeit für eine
langfristige und umfassende
fachkräftestrategie die Lage ist hier
das wissen wir in den Branchen den
Berufen durchaus differenziert während
es in einigen Bereichen absehbar
Menschen gibt die Qualifikation haben
die ihnen große Sorgen bereiten ob Sie
auch morgen noch gebraucht werden ob sie
morgen noch einen Job haben gibt es
andere Bereiche in den schon heute
händeringend Fachkräfte gesucht werden
sollen beispielsweise die Klima und
energieeffizienzziele der
Bundesregierung eingehalten werden
braucht es laut IG Metall und der
handwerksverbände allein im
Gebäudesektor über 150.000 zusätzliche
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker die eine
Antwort auf diese Herausforderung gibt
es sicherlich nicht aber mit dem Zögern
und Zaudern der letzten Jahre muss hier
endlich schlussnahme damit werden
erstens wer sich um qualifizierte
Fachkräfte für die Zukunft sorgt der
muss zunächst einmal für verbesserte
Berufsorientierung ausreichend
ausreichend Ausbildungsplätze und vor
allem auch gute Ausbildungsbedingungen
in den Betrieben kümmern als Fraktion
DIE LINKE begrüßen wir ausdrücklich das
Forum der bundesregungen
Ausbildungsgarantie zu schaffen aber die
Wahrheit liegt bekanntlich auf dem Platz
eine echte Ausbildungsgarantie gibt es
nur mit mehr betrieblichen
Ausbildungsplätzen und einer
solidarischen Finanzierung der
beruflichen Ausbildung über eine
Ausbildungsplatz Umlage die diejenigen
Betriebe unterstützen tatsächlich
ausbilden und junge Menschen nicht in
zweitklassige außerbetriebliche
Ausbildung Abschied
und ja wir brauchen da mehr öffentliche
Investitionen in die Berufsschulen und
vielleicht sollten wir auch hier
tatsächlich mal über einen
entsprechenden berufsschulpakt zwischen
Bund und Ländern nachdenken damit auch
die Berufsschulen entsprechend gefördert
werden wie das in anderen Bereichen des
Bildungssystems schon der Fall ist
zweitens der insbesondere die berufliche
Ausbildung attraktiv machen will der
muss auch für attraktive
Arbeitsbedingungen sorgen nicht nur
damit mehr junge Menschen sich für die
Ausbildung entscheiden sondern auch
damit sie nach ihrer Ausbildung auch
tatsächlich im Beruf bleiben das
Versagen der Bundesregierung der letzten
und bei der aktuellen ist er ja nichts
besseres zu erkennen für anständige
Arbeitsbedingungen in der Pflege zu
sorgen führt jetzt die Folgen der nutze
deutlich vor Augen immer mehr guten
qualifizierte Pflegekräfte verlassen den
Beruf oder gehen in Teilzeit weil sie
bestehende Belastungen nicht mehr
aushalten damit muss endlich Schluss
damit
deshalb ist es absolut schädlich wenn
sie von der Union jetzt in ihrem Antrag
längere tägliche Arbeitszeiten fordern
damit würde sich die Arbeitsbedingungen
vieler Menschen verschlechtern und das
Fachkräfteproblem nicht verkleinert
sondern vergrößert meine Damen und
Herren und genauso unsäglich ist ihr
anhaltender Versuch Erwerbslose gegen
Beschäftigte auszuspielen dieses Jahr
auch in dem vorliegenden Antrag wieder
versuchen natürlich ist es richtig dass
ich Arbeit und die Aufnahme einer Arbeit
lohnen muss aber doch nicht indem man
diejenigen die eh kaum etwas haben doch
das existenzminum streitig macht was wir
dringend brauchen sind flächendeckend
Tarifverträge der für sorgen dass Arbeit
auch überall besser und anständig
bezahlt wird meine Damen und Herren
drittens wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
auch diejenigen die ohne Job sind oder
die Angst haben ihren Job zu verlieren
aufgrund der großen Transformation die
wir durchmachen dass die auch
entsprechend Unterstützung bekommen und
entsprechend qualifiziert werden da
braucht es entsprechende Anreize damit
Qualifikation qualifizieren besser
dasteht als irgendein billig-job den man
mal kurzfristig aufnimmt das muss ich
ändern dafür brauchen wir passgenaue
Angebote ein echtes Weiterbildungsgeld
meine Damen und Herren
und viertens wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass auch diejenigen die in den letzten
Jahren nach Deutschland oder in diesem
Jahr nach Deutschland geflohen sind vor
Krieg elendverfolgung dass die auch
entsprechend unterstützt werden
umfassende Sprachkurse sozusagen und das
nicht als demütiges betteln um
Sprachkurse tatsächlich von Anfang an
umfassen eine schnellere Anerkennung von
Berufsqualifikationen die vorhanden sind
und vor allen Dingen mehr Angebote um
gegebenenfalls
Anpassungsqualifizierungen auch schnell
durchführen zu können ich komme zum
Schluss klar ist auch auf eine
waagedachstrategie wie sie das von der
Bundesregierung so schön nennen kann man
sich nicht verlassen wir brauchen ein
verbindlichen Masterplan für die
Fachkräfte Sicherung sofort umgesetzt
wird vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie alle ganz herzlich an diesem
Freitagvormittag und möchte nur noch mal
darauf hinweisen weil mir das auch
gestern schon auffiel fangen Sie bitte
nicht an in die Schlussgerade zu kommen
wenn ihre Redezeit schon überschritten
ist sondern dann sollte möglichst auch
tatsächlich das Ende irgendwie geschafft
sein aber jetzt bekommt erstmal das Wort
Pascal Kober für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin der
Fachkräftemangel ist neben Corona und
der im energiekrieg Putins gegen
Deutschland die größte
wohlstandsgefährdung unserer Zeit für
unsere Volkswirtschaft mittlerweile hat
das eine Dimension angenommen das
Forscher und sagen dass der
Fachkräftemangel jährlich 86 Milliarden
Euro an Wirtschaftsleistung kostet und
das ist ein Problem das nicht vom Himmel
gefallen ist sondern dass ich Jahr für
Jahr aufgebaut hat das hat nämlich etwas
mit dem demografischen Wandel zu tun und
nichts ist sicherer als die
demografische Statistik ein Kind was
heute nicht geboren ist ist morgen nicht
auf der Welt sie als Union haben dieses
Thema nicht etwa verschlafen sie haben
es verweigert über Jahre hier eine
Lösung herbeizuführen und das muss hier
an dieser Stelle auch noch mal bemerkt
werden
sie wollen nicht zur Lösung beitragen
weil sie sich einer eigenen Lebenslüge
oder zumindest eines Lebens Irrtums
nicht entledigen können sie wissen ganz
genau dass die Forscher und sagen dass
wir mittlerweile jährlich eine
Zuwanderung von 400.000 Menschen in
unseren Arbeitsmarkt brauchen
qualifizierte Zuwanderung auch die
Arbeitsministerin Ursula von der Leyen
hatte das schon vor zwölf Jahren ihnen
ihre eigene Fraktion in Stammbuch
geschrieben sie haben sie damals
blockiert wir als FDP hätten damals
schon die richtigen Weichen gestellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
ihr Antrag heute zeigt aber dass sie
noch keinen Schritt weiter sind und das
ist nicht in Ordnung
sie müssen sich der Wahrheit stellen
dass der Fachkräftemangel nur durch
gesteuerte qualifizierte
erwerbsmigration möglich sein kann und
in ihrem Antrag schlagen Sie jetzt
ausschließlich Themen vor die natürlich
den innerer den inneren
Fachkräftepotenzial zu zu wecken in der
Lage sind gar keine Frage aber wenn man
sich mal die 22 Forderungen Ihres
Antrags anschaut dann stellt man doch
erstaunlich fest mit welchen Maßnahmen
sie daran angehen wollen
Schulabbrecherquote reduzieren
Berufsorientierung an Schulen verbessern
und schulpläne Anpassen außerdem finden
sich in ihrem Antrag Forderungen wie
Bildungsabschlüsse mit anderen
miteinander vergleichbar machen und die
Kinderbetreuung verbessern das sind
alles tolle und richtige Vorschläge
allein die Umsetzung oblieb der
Bundesländer und der Kommunen sie
verschieben die Verantwortung auf andere
dass es zu wenig für eine
Bundestagsfraktion und im übrigen sind
das auch alles nur Appelle ohne
Lösungswege das ist erst recht zu wenig
für
Bundestagsfraktion es ist richtig dass
wir das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial des
Inlandes natürlich besser nutzen müssen
dass wir da Vorankommen müssen und das
tut ja auch diese Regierung und jetzt
komme ich zum letzten Vorschlag für eine
gute Oppositionsarbeit lesen Sie auch
die Anträge und die Gesetzentwürfe der
Regierung dann würden sie nämlich sehen
dass wir mit dem neuen Bürgergeld genau
das in Angriff genommen haben dass wir
die Menschen besser qualifizieren um sie
nachhaltig in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union es war ein Versuch
wir erwarten auf Besserung
Pascal Kober von der FDP hat gesagt es
war ein Versuch mal sehen was Katrin
Staffler jetzt dazu sagt von der CDU ist
tsu sie Sprecherin der CSU Landesgruppe
für Innovation Bildung und Forschung
[Applaus]
für uns Bildungspolitikern gehört zu den
schönsten Aufgaben und Terminen das wird
zur Abschluss und Abschluss und
freisprechungsfeiern gehen dürfen es ist
unglaublich schön da die jungen Leute
sitzen zu sehen die begierig darauf
warten dass die in ihrem Beruf
durchstarten dass sie endlich anfangen
damit worauf sie zwei drei Jahre lang
hingearbeitet haben und ich finde es ist
ansteckend das ist ansteckend mit was
für einem Enthusiasmus muss was für ein
Tatendrang die jungen Leute bei diesen
freien vor einem sitzen und die vollen
Seele bei den Feiern zeigen uns auch
dass es die Fachkräfte von morgen ja
durchaus gibt es sind halt leider zu
wenige ja das System schwächelt und das
nicht erst seit Corona die Bildung die
berufliche Bildung war in der
Vergangenheit immer ein
unterschiedlicher Garant für unseren
wirtschaftlichen Erfolg und genau so
muss es in Zukunft auch bleiben weil und
lassen Sie mich das in aller
Deutlichkeit formulieren ohne Fachkräfte
keine Wirtschaft keine florierende
Wirtschaft ohne Fachkräfte keine
gesunden Unternehmen ohne Fachkräfte
keine Energie und Klimawende und so
weiter und so fort diese Aufzählung
ließen sich beliebig fortführen
und jetzt sage ich es ihnen ganz ehrlich
ich glaube noch nicht mal dass wir in
der Feststellung im disent sind aber
genau deswegen habe ich mich die letzten
Monate so gewundert dass so wenig von
dieser Regierung zu diesem Thema kommt
warum weil nämlich die Blaupause für all
die dringend benötigten Maßnahmen die
jetzt auf den Weg gebracht werden müssen
schon lange auf den Tisch liegt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie erinnern
sich vielleicht der ein oder andere von
Ihnen wir haben in der letzten
Legislaturperiode gemeinsam ne und
cat-kommission einberufen die
Zukunftsfragen der beruflichen Bildung
thematisiert hat wir haben drei Jahre
lang parteiübergreifend mit
Sachverständigen mit Experten gearbeitet
und wir haben in diesem recht
umfangreichen Werk fast 600 detaillierte
Empfehlungen aufgelistet und zwar
Empfehlungen wie wir in Deutschland
unser berufliches Bildungssystem
zukunftsfest ausbauen können und wie wir
es attraktiver gestalten können
wir haben damit alle gemeinsam dem
aktuellen Gesetzgeber einen
Maßnahmenplan an die Hand gegeben
und das einfache ist das schöne ist er
muss jetzt eigentlich einfach nur noch
umgesetzt werden und wenn ich mir ihre
Reden hier im Plenum zu dieser Debatte
gerade einfach hier zu alle anhört dann
beschleicht mich das Gefühl dass die
allermeisten von ihnen in dem Bericht
nicht mehr wirklich reingeschaut haben
geschweige denn dass sie den Willen
haben die Empfehlungen die wir da
reingeschrieben haben umzusetzen
es geht bei der aus- und Weiterbildung
unserer Fachkräfte um eine komplexe
Aufgabe ja es geht um eine wichtige
Aufgabe ganz sicher es geht um eine
Aufgabe zu deren Bewältigung wir ein
mindest ebenso komplexes und
ineinandergreifendes Maßnahmenpaket
begnötigen das ist also genau das was
man hier drin aufgeschrieben haben ganz
genau das und dieser Aufgabe wird leider
die Ampelkoalition bislang sorry wenn
ich das sage nicht im Ansatz gerecht zu
den zentralen Forderungen die wir
aufgestellt haben zählen zum Beispiel
eine bessere Unterstützung junger
Menschen bei der Berufsorientierung
Umsetzung unterschiedlichster Maßnahmen
zu Attraktivitätssteigerung beruflicher
Ausbildung wie die Stärkung von
überbetrieblicher Ausbildung eine
Exzellenzinitiative für Berufsschule
verbesserte Angebote zur Steigerung der
Mobilität an den deutschen beruflichen
Austauschdienst Maßnahmen für mehr
Transparenz und Vergleichbarkeit von
Bildungsabschlüssen zum Beispiel im DQR
eine Stärkung des Lebens begleitenden
Lernens insbesondere auch für die
Quereinsteiger
expliziert und so weiter und so fort
könnte ich noch lange vorher sie sagen
alle wunderbar
er dann frage ich mich wieso sie ihr
unseren Antrag so schlecht finden das
kommt ihnen nämlich vielleicht bekannt
vor das ist genau das was in unserem
Antrag drin steht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es sind auch die Dinge die wir vor Grad
einmal gut einem Jahr
fraktionsübergreifend und das will ich
an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen
einstimmig auch mit den Stimmen der
Kollegen der SPD den Stimmen der
Kollegen von den Grünen den Stimmen der
FDP beschlossen haben in der
onkettebericht und man fragt sich jetzt
ehrlicherweise schon warum sie sich hier
alle hinstellen und erzählen dass das
alles misst wer was wir in dem Antrag
schreiben also liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus den ampelfraktionen
natürlich weisen sie jetzt in der
Debatte darauf hin auf die in dieser
Woche beschlossene fachkräftestrategie
dass sie das ein oder andere ja da
ohnehin umsetzen wollen es gibt da ein
Problem jetzt nehmen wir zum Beispiel
mal das Thema
Exzellenzinitiative berufliche Bildung
im Koalitionsvertrag angekündigt wird in
einem Satz in dieser Strategie von ihnen
erwähnt aber bitte nur einen Satz sie
sind schon über die Zeit es gibt
allerdings überhaupt keine konkreten
Ausführungen zur Ausgestaltungen wir
brauchen keine Strategien ohne Plan wie
sie umgesetzt worden da hat der Bäcker
nichts davon der Friseur nicht das
Pflegeheim genauso wenig
das tue ich lassen sie uns nicht an
unausgegorene Strategien Arbeiten packen
sie einsetzen
sie sind fertig wunderbar danke
Aydan ösus sehr hartnäckig aber in der
Sache hat sie natürlich recht wenn das
Licht gelingt dann heißt das für den
Redner zum Ende zu kommen und das kann
ja auch ein bisschen dauern
indem sie bei 0 am Ende sind nicht so
sie sehen ja die Zeit vor sich so wir
versuchen es wieder für die
Sozialdemokratie kommt jetzt Rascha
ist im Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
von der SPD
ich muss zunächst zu den Kollegen Herrn
Dr Wiener und Frau Hue was sagen denn es
ärgert mich schon dass wir über
Fachkräftegewinnung im Inland sprechen
und sie ihre Zeit dafür verwenden gegen
Menschen aus dem Ausland zu hetzen ich
verstehe es nicht warum das immer und
immer wieder passiert gerade der
Spurwechsel gerade der Spurwechsel Herr
Dr Wiener ist richtig ich war
Integrationsbeauftragte im Freiberg
anderthalb Jahre in dieser Zeit habe ich
mehrere Auszubildende in den Betrieben
gab die aus dem Betrieb heraus
abgeschoben worden erklären Sie den
Betrieben noch mal was an dem
Spurwechsel so doof ist das gut
qualifizierte Leute hier rausgeholt
werden das muss nicht sein
wir stehen vor großen Herausforderungen
wenn wir über das Thema Fachkräfte
Sicherung sprechen und wir nehmen uns
der Verantwortung an Menschen Sicherheit
im Wandel zu geben erst am Mittwoch hat
Hubertus Heil in Abstimmung mit einem
zuständigen Ressorts die
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
vorgestellt und dafür möchte ich mich
bedanken denn da stehen sehr viele
wichtige und richtungsweisende Punkte
drin und ich freue mich diese mit ihnen
allen gemeinsam weiter mit Leben zu
füllen ich möchte als erstes betonwerte
Union dass ich ihren Antrag ganz gerne
gelesen habe denn an ihm ließ sich ja
eigentlich ganz gut erkennen dass wir
zumindest an einigen Stellen dass wir
zumindest an einigen Stellen gar nicht
so weit voneinander entfernt sind und es
gibt mir dann doch Hoffnung für die
weiteren Beratungen der
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
zum Beispiel der Aspekt der
Frauenerwerbstätigkeit es ist ein Unding
dass Frauen am Arbeitsmarkt immer noch
so ungleich behandelt werden und viel
öfter in Teilzeit arbeiten weniger
Arbeitsstunden bedeuten kleinere Löhne
bedeuten kleinere Renten und altersarmut
ist besonders bei Frauen ein großes
Problem also müssen wir unter anderem
Infrastruktur aus und aufbauen zum
Beispiel durch bessere flächendeckende
Kinderbetreuung oder Ganztagsschulen für
alle Kinder in ganz Deutschland
wir müssen aber auch dafür sorgen dass
Kinderbetreuung Hausarbeit oder
pflegeeben nicht nur auf den Schultern
der Frauen lastet die Frauen
Erwerbstätigkeit wird nämlich auch dann
weiter steigen wenn diese Aufgaben
endlich partnerschaftlich verteilt sind
es braucht also nicht nur eine
Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und Familie für
Mütter sondern eine Vereinbarkeit von
Beruf und Familie für alle
wenn man sich die engpass-berufe genauer
anschaut dann fällt auf das besonders da
Fachkräftemangel herrscht vor
eigengeschlecht über beziehungsweise
unterrepräsentiert ist in den sozialen
Berufen sehen wir überdurchschnittlich
viele Frauen während wir zum Beispiel im
Handwerk sehr sehr viele Männer sehen
dabei bin ich der festen Überzeugung
alles was ein Mann kann kann eine Frau
auch und umgekehrt erst da kann man mal
klatschen
erst vorgestern haben Kolleginnen der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und ich gemeinsam
mit Sozialpartnern und
Arbeitgeberverbänden aus dem Handwerk
zusammengesessen und uns beraten und die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben recht
wenn sie sagen dass wir eine breite
Allianz zur Stärkung des Handwerks
brauchen denn gerade dort brauchen wir
die vielen klugen und gut ausgebildeten
Menschen nur mit ihnen werden wir die
Herausforderungen der Verkehrswende der
bauwände oder auch der Digitalisierung
schaffen und das ist mir auch und
besonders für Ostdeutschland wichtig
denn bei uns vor Ort wird weniger
ausgebildet dabei ist Ostdeutschland so
ein schöner Landstrich ich kann das
bestätigen wir wollen Unternehmen dabei
unterstützen mit einem
qualifizierungsgeld ihre Fachkräfte
weiter zu qualifizieren zu halten und
sich so besser und breiter aufzustellen
und andererseits geben wir jungen
Menschen mit der Ausbildungsgarantie des
Recht auf einem guten Ausbildungsplatz
in der Transformation der Arbeitswelt
ist Weiterbildungen wichtiger Faktor und
deshalb freue ich mich dass Hubertus
Heil das Ziel ausgegeben hat die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zur
weiterbildungsrepublik für alle zu
machen
wir wollen zum Beispiel Menschen im SGB
II mit dem weiterbildungsbonus die
Möglichkeit geben sich nachhaltig aus
der Arbeitslosigkeit herauszuarbeiten
und dann wieder in den Arbeitsmarkt
einzusteigen und damit komme ich zu
einem Punkt werteunion in ihrem Antrag
der mir so gar nicht gefällt wir haben
gestern in erster Lesung des
bürgergeldgesetz beraten und da haben
sie schon wieder wie in Punkt 16 Ihres
Antrags nachzulesen gefordert die Zitat
ausgesetzten Sanktionen wegen
Pflichtverletzungen für arbeitsfähige
Bezieher von Grundsicherung umgehend
wieder einzuführen und damit Anreize für
die auf- und Annahme von angebotener
Arbeit wieder zu erhöhen da haben wir
ein ganz anderes Menschenbild ihr
Vertrauen Menschen wir vertrauen
Menschen wir wollen Sie ermutigen und
echte Anreize schaffen und ich bin sehr
sicher dass der Grundsatz Anreiz durch
Bestrafung ausgedient
wir stehen für Ausbildung vor
Aushilfsjob und nachhaltiger Integration
vor sinnloser Vermittlung wir werden
deshalb natürlich keinem Antrag
zustimmen der unter anderem die wir
Aufnahme der ausgesetzten Sanktionen
fordert und eine bitte noch an Sie liebe
Union wir freuen uns sehr über
Vorschläge von ihm was Einwanderung aus
dem Ausland von Fachkräften angeht auch
das haben sie heute wieder missen lassen
vielen Dank
die Null getroffen zu haben zumindest
kein Widerspruch von der Präsidentin
in der Debatte Enrico Comlink von der
AFD er ist Mitglied im
Wirtschaftsausschuss und hat jetzt das
Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren Kollegen liebe Besucher
auf den Tribünen nach 16 Jahren CDU
Merkel und einem Jahr rot-Grün ist es
wahrscheinlich dass wir in Zukunft nicht
mehr über Fachkräftemangel sondern über
arbeitsstellenmangel diskutieren werden
und dennoch werden wir in Deutschland
auch in Zukunft jede Fachkraft jeden
Ingenieur jede Krankenschwester und
jeden Tischler brauchen wenn wir aus dem
Totalschaden Deutschland wieder einen
Sportwagen machen wollen
in diesem Zusammenhang freut mich ihr
Antrag der Kollegen von der Union ganz
besonders es freut mich dass sie sich
neuerdings auch für die Förderung
inländischer Fachkräfte interessieren
und nicht nur für insozialsystem
eingewanderte vermeintliche Architekten
und Ärzte
fachkräftezuwanderung so wie sie sie
auch in diesem Antrag hier verstehen ist
ein Irrweg er behebt den
Fachkräftemangel nicht und kostet den
Steuerzahler und abgabenzahler
Milliarden und das meine Damen und
Herren machen wir so nicht mit
was ihr heute fordern ist in vielen
Punkten im übrigen dasselbe was meiner
afd-bundestagsfraktion schon vor gut
zwei Jahren im Bundestag hier zur
Abstimmung vorgelegt hat was freilich
von den von dem sozialistischen
einheitswirr war von
rot-grün-gelb und auch schwarz
zurückgewiesen wurde aber was vor zwei
Jahren richtig war ist auch ist es auch
heute noch und so nehmen wir Ihre
Einsicht mit Genugtuung zur Kenntnis
auch wenn sie reichlich spät kommt und
wenn wir schon bei ihren Einsichten sind
liebe Kollegen von der Union dann sorgen
Sie doch mit uns gleich dafür dass die
Beschäftigung einheimischer
Arbeitskräfte wieder der Vorrang
eingeräumt wird streichen wir einfach
die entsprechenden Vorschriften im
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz dann und
erst dann wird Ihr Antrag
zustimmungsfähig wir können uns
rot-grüne weltbeglückungsfantasien
schlicht nicht mehr leisten unser Land
zuerst
ihr Antrag liebe Kollegen bleibt beim
Thema Bürokratie seltsam Waage werden
sie doch konkret schaffen sie zum
Beispiel diese sinnlose
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht endlich
ab und ermöglichen wir es wieder
tausenden vollqualifizierten
Pflegekräften wieder ihren Job zu machen
und stärken wir die berufliche Bildung
unser duales Ausbildungssystem ist
weltweit geachtet wir brauchen mehr
fertige Meister und weniger gescheiterte
Master
meine Damen und Herren den
Fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen heißt den
Mittelstand zu stärken mit ihrer
Energiewende mit ihrer schulden-politik
mit ihrer Währungspolitik haben sie die
Existenz von Millionen von Menschen
gefährdet widmen wir uns mehr denn je
dem einzig wirklichen deutschen Rohstoff
der Bildung und der Ausbildung unserer
inländischen Fachkräfte vielen Dank
[Applaus]
es folgt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Winkelmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister Heil Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger Liebe Union
sie haben sich wie ich Ihren Antrag
entnehmen kann bei uns bei der Ampel
informiert sie haben sich eingegriffen
in konkrete Vorhaben zur fachung
arbeitskräftestrategie aber aus unseren
konkret kommenden Initiativen und
Strategien einen Antrag zu formulieren
mit Punkten die wir ja schon angekündigt
haben teilweise in Angriff nehmen
aufsetzen ist überflüssige Bürokratie
und widerspricht sich gleich direkt mit
ihrer Forderung zum Thema
Entbürokratisierung
sie Listen in ihren Antrag ihre
Versäumnisse aus 16 Jahren Regierung auf
diese Einsicht ist wichtig und gut
einfache Maßnahmen ohne großen
bürokratischen Aufwand
Berufsorientierung und eine aus- und
Weiterbildung die unter anderem
Handwerksbetriebe Industrie und zum
Pflegebereich passt das wird gebraucht
und das liefern wir
junge Menschen müssen Unterstützung
bekommen ihre erste Berufsentscheidung
gezielt zu treffen die zu Ihnen passt
aber die Berufsorientierung muss breiter
aufgestellt sein nicht zu einseitig wie
in ihren Antrag Berufsorientierung heißt
nicht nur an die jungen Menschen
rangehen nein an die ganze Gesellschaft
und unsere Vielfältigkeit und sie
Möglichkeiten somit allen aufzuzeigen
und Menschen
Menschen brauchen gezielte aus- und
Weiterbildung die schaffen wir mit
unserer Maßnahmen gewinnen wir Fach und
Arbeitskräfte gezielt und zwar aus dem
In- und Ausland und ich stelle mir die
Frage ob Sie Ihren Antrag mit ihren
Landesregierungen abgestimmt haben weil
es glaube ich nicht also ich habe ein
lieblingspassage aus ihrem Antrag fehlen
die Fachkräfte werden Windräder nicht
errichten Solaranlagen nicht
installieren Gebäude nicht energetisch
sanieren so wie konnte jetzt den das
passieren sie haben wohl ihre Pläne der
letzten 16 Jahre die Branche der
Erneuerbaren auszubauen und somit für
die Zukunftsbranche schlechthin
qualifiziert die Arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen so geheim gehalten dass sich
selber nicht wussten
hätten sie die Erneuerbaren
vorangebracht die nachhaltigen und
Energiesparen Wohnungsbau gefördert
statt zu stoppen und ja in manchen
Bundesländern sogar komplett zum
Erliegen gebracht wäre unsere
Energieabhängigkeit jetzt eine andere
und Deutschland hätte die Fachkräfte
und hier geht ein schöner Gruß
insbesondere an mein Heimatbundesland
Bayern die Staatsregierung dort
blockiert ja aus bekannten Gründen den
Ausbau zum Beispiel der Windenergie so
aber wir lesen jetzt mal aus ihren
Antrag heraus sie wollen uns hier
unterstützen aber da müssen sie sich
beeilen wir haben hier einen richtig
hohes Tempo eben schon vorgelegt und
warum war es pressiert wir tun das weil
Eile geboten ist
wir haben es im Koalitionsvertrag stehen
und wir werden es umsetzen wir machen
Deutschland zur aus- und
weiterbildungsrepublik die Fachkräfte
von heute und morgen bringen wir auf
einen zukunftsfähigen weg und jetzt
aufgepasst Fach und Arbeitskräfte aus in
und Ausland
wir als Ampel haben schon einiges auf
den Weg gebracht und bringen dieses Jahr
noch einiges auf den Weg und Liebe Union
ihren Antrag braucht man halt dafür
nicht danke schön
für die cdu/csu-fraktion folgt Marc
biadatz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ganz am Anfang
möchte ich doch was sagen Herr outretsch
sie haben heute etwas falsch gemacht die
Parteitagsrede die sie heute Mittag auf
dem Parteitag der Grünen halten wollen
die haben Sie heute hier schon im
Parlament gehalten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Bundeskanzler Helmut Schmidt hat einmal
richtig gesagt Demokratie besteht aus
Debatte und anschließender Entscheidung
aufgrund der Debatte in ihrer
ampelregierung allerdings sehen wir fast
ausschließlich Debatten und leider nur
zögerliche und viel zu späte
Entscheidungen
und das in einer Zeit in der Deutschland
und Europa vor immensen Herausforderung
steht doch statt entschlossen und
schnell zu handeln verliert sich die
Ampel in koalitionsstreitigkeiten und
ideologischen Debatten diese Folgen
dieser tödlichen ampelpolitik spüren die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Ihrem
Geldbeutel denn überall steigen die
Preise und die Entlastungen lassen auf
sich warten die Gründe für die Inflation
sind vielfältig natürlich sind es vor
allem die steigenden Energiekosten aber
auch die fehlenden Arbeitskräfte
belastende Preise und Wirtschaft die
schlimmste Auswirkung des Mangels an
Fach und Arbeitskräften ist allerdings
wie sehr er unser Land lebt im
Baugewerbe fehlen Facharbeiter um
dringend benötigte Wohnungen zu bauen in
Behörden bleiben Anträge liegen weil
Personal fehlt Heizungsbauer fehlen um
neue Pumpen einzubauen fehlende Fach-
und Arbeitskräfte Schwächen nicht nur
unseren Wirtschaftsstandort sondern auch
unsere Fähigkeit auf Krisen zu reagieren
und diese zu lösen 43 Prozent der
Unternehmen müssen aufgrund der
fehlenden Fach- und Arbeitskräfte ihre
Angebotspalette einschränken oh sogar
Aufträge ablehnen 59 Prozent der
Unternehmen geben sogar an dass der
Fachkräftemangel für Sie eins der
größten Geschäftsrisiken ist als Union
begrüßen wir Liebe Koalition dass die
Bundesregierung sich auf dem Thema auf
dem Weg macht ist eine
fachkräftessicherungsstrategie auf die
Agenda setzt das ist gut und richtig so
doch leider sehe ich nicht wie sie mit
ihren bisherigen Vorschlägen in
absehbarer Zeit Abhilfe für diese
Belastung unseres Arbeitsmarkt schaffen
wollen statt von Problemlösungen ist
ihre Arbeitsmarktpolitik gekennzeichnet
von sozialdemokratischer
Vergangenheitsbewältigung sie liebe
Ampel
sie liebe Ampel schaffen Hartz IV ab und
mit dem Bürgergeld den Einstieg in ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
einzuleiten
das ist nicht nur teuer sondern auch
absolut der falsche Weg für unseren
Arbeitsmarkt überall werden
Arbeitskräfte gesucht und sie machen
Arbeit weiter unattraktiver
sie verabschieden sich vom Prinzip
fordern und fördern und damit von einer
zentralen Stärke unseres Arbeitsmarktes
ihm geht es ausschließlich um
schaufensterpolitik statt konkrete
Hilfen für den Arbeitsmarkt sie sprechen
von dringend benötigen Fachkräften aber
senden völlig gegensätzliche Signale in
unserem heutigen Antrag machen wir Ihnen
konkrete Vorschläge um Fach- und
Arbeitskräfte mit zielgerichteten
Maßnahmen im Inland zu sichern und zu
gewinnen wir hoffen dass diese auch im
Arbeitsministerium gelesen werden dazu
gehören unter anderem die Aktivitäten
zur Vermittlung von Ausbildungsplätzen
auszubauen duale Ausbildung weiterhin
stärker zu fördern in lindnerisches
Arbeitspotenzial zu mobilisieren und
weiter an Weiterbildungsangebote
konsequent auszubauen mit der digitalen
Lernplattform Miller haben wir übrigens
ihnen da auch einen guten Vorschlag
gemacht ich kann Ihnen den gerne auch
mal in nächster Zeit weiter erklären und
meine Damen und Herren doch in keinem
dieser Bereiche schafft die
Bundesregierung eine zu viel
zufriedenstellende Antwort was wir jetzt
brauchen ist ein Arbeitsmarkt der es mit
den Menschen ermöglicht ihre eigene
Zukunft zu gestalten anstatt die
Menschen zu verwalten uns als Union ist
es wichtig wir wollen niemanden
zurücklassen denn liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel sie kommen uns
immer wieder mit 16 Jahren unsere
Regierungszeit doch im Bereich der
Arbeitsmarktpolitik müssen wir
feststellen nie war unser Arbeitsmarkt
so stark und wie stabil wie unter der
Führung der cdu/csu-bundesregierung
wir fordern sie auf kehren die zurück zu
einem vernünftigen Weg und die Erfolge
der Arbeitsmarktpolitik der letzten
Jahre werden auch vielleicht ihre
Erfolge sein herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag debattiert über einen
Antrag der
cocsu-fraktion Gewinnung von Fach und
Arbeitskräften im Inland Manfred
totenhausen für die FDP hat jetzt das
Wort er ist der handwerkspolitische
Sprecher seiner Fraktion meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich finde es
ja gut dass wir uns in einigen Punkten
tatsächlich auch einig sind und wir
müssen heute heute müssen wir uns um die
aus- und Weiterbildung unserer
Fachkräfte kümmern damit wir sie morgen
haben wir brauchen Sie in allen
Bereichen ob als klimawerker
Baufachleute oder als Mitarbeiter im
Gesundheitssystem oder in der Pflege
allein im Handwerk fehlen 250.000
ausgebildete Fachkräfte in den Klima
Gewerken sind es 60.000 diese enormen
Lücken müssen geschlossen werden neben
der neben einer generellen geregelten
Zuwanderung gehört mehr aus- und
Weiterbildung im Inland dazu aber das
Thema ist ja nicht neu das Thema ist ja
nicht der Bundestag hat dazu in dessen
Wahlperiode eine onkette-kommission
einberufen an der ich auch mitarbeiten
durfte und sie hat viele gute Ideen und
Empfehlungen auf dem Weg gebracht die
auch heute eine Bedeutung haben in ihrem
Antrag finde ich dazu sogar einige
Ansätze ich erwähne nur digitale
Lernplattform oder den Aufbau eines
deutschen beruflichen Austauschdienstes
aber beim Lesen Ihrer Wünsche frage ich
mich dennoch ich weiß sie können es
lange nicht mehr hören wer stellt in
diesem Jahr eigentlich 16 Jahre lang die
bundesbildungsministeriumministerin und
wer hat auf den Trend gesetzt dass wir
immer mehr Akademiker brauchen während
gleichzeitig die berufliche Bildung ins
Hintertreffen geraten ist es waren ihre
drei Ministerinnen Liebe Union erst Frau
Karliczek erst Frau Karliczek hat am
Ende versucht hier umzusteuern und
lieber Herr Wiener sie haben den Elektro
jetzt ist er weg jetzt hat er hat den
elektroberuf gelernt er ist immer noch
da wo heute den elektroberuch ich übe
ihn bis heute aus und Sie werden dann
lieber Elektriker geblieben kann ich
Ihnen nur sagen Vorhaben wir die meine
Damen und Herren vorher haben wir die
existenzinitiative berufliche Bildung
und der Ausbau der Berufsorientierung
werden bereits von der Ampel umgesetzt
andere Projekte finden Sie in eine
umfassenden
fachkräftestrategie die die
Bundesregierung gerade erst auf den Weg
gebracht hat und wenn jetzt nach mir
ginge gibt es bald neben der dem
freiwilligen sozialen und ökologischen
Jahr auch das freiwillige Jahr in den
Klima Gewerken da gibt es sicher eine
hohe Nachfrage und bei dieser Koalition
ist die fachkräfteentwicklung in guten
Händen ein gutes Beispiel wir waren es
dir den Haushaltstitel für die
überbetrieblichen Lehrwerkstätten von 49
Millionen auf 70 Millionen erhört haben
erhöht haben unsere uns ist wichtig
sowohl die Ausbildung attraktiver zu
machen als auch die Ausbildungsbetriebe
zu entlasten die Betriebe finden dabei
nicht nur die unstoßstützung in den
Fraktionen sondern auch in unserer
Regierung unsere Bildungsministerin
Bettina stark Watzinger steht absolut
hinter der Gleichwertigkeit von
beruflicher und akademischer Bildung
nach bald einem Jahr Ampelkoalition sind
wir auf einen guten Weg den wir
weitergehen werden vielen Dank
ja nicht gut erzogen Frau
ja das machen sie alle jetzt sehr gut
als nächstes folgt für die SPD-Fraktion
Manuel garver
ja da hat sich einen vs offensichtlich
durchgesetzt Manuel gawa SPD und wir
sind tatsächlich sehr gut im Zeitplan
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wenn einem einen Antrag
aus der Opposition die Möglichkeit gibt
über die ein oder andere Errungenschaft
aus der Regierungskoalition zu sprechen
ist das ein gutes Zeichen gerade einem
Freitag liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der cdu/csu ich bin sehr froh dass sie
die Fachkräfte Strategie der
Bundesregierung aufmerksam gelesen haben
an der Stelle herzlichen Dank an
Minister Heil da ist sogar noch viel
mehr drin als in ihrem Antrag zum
Beispiel das neue Bürgergeld und kein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen von dem
ich eben schon das ein oder andere Mal
gehört habe im Januar 2023 tritt das in
Kraft das neue Bürgergeld ist eine
Maßnahme die es Menschen ermöglicht
wieder in Würde und mit neuen
Perspektiven am Arbeitsmarkt bereit zu
stehen eigentlich müssten sie dem ja
zustimmen zumindest wenn wir mal die
sank rauslassen gibt es da sicher
Möglichkeiten dass sie dem auch
zustimmen können mit dem Bürgergeld
werden Anreize und die Aufnahmen von
besuchsbezogenen Weiterbildungen
verbessert und das durch den
erleichterten Zugang zu aus- und
Weiterbildungsangeboten sowie einem
Weiterbildungsgeld ich finde das ist ein
richtig guter Schritt in die richtige
Richtung darüber hinaus
darüber hinaus ermöglichen wir den
Menschen einen neuen beruflichen Weg zu
gehen und den Faden wieder aufzunehmen
wir wollen mit und nicht gegen die
Menschen arbeiten ihnen keine Steine in
den Weg legen oder sie in kurzfristige
und unsichere Anstellungen hineindrängen
indem sie wenig Perspektive und keine
Möglichkeiten haben sich
weiterzuentwickeln dass wir das
verändern ist richtig gut so
und es ist ja schon lange nicht mehr so
dass man nach der Schule einen Beruf
ergreift und den sein ganzes Leben dann
durchführt eine Lebenslage berufliche
Weiterentwicklung wird einem in der
aktuellen und zukünftigen Arbeitswelt
abverlangt unsere Aufgabe ist es die
Menschen gut auf diesen Weg
vorzubereiten eine neue Ausbildung und
somit auch neue Lebensabschnitte
einzugehen das geht in der Schule mit
einem fundierten und zielführenden
Berufsorientierung los und geht bis an
das Ende des arbeitlebens aber auch die
ArbeitgeberInnen Arbeitgeber haben mir
eine Verantwortung ihre Beschäftigten
durch Prävention Weiterbildungsangebote
und Bedingungen für eine altersgerechte
Arbeit zu ermöglichen Attraktivität
einer Arbeitsstelle hört schließlich
nicht beim Gehalt auf auch in den
Unternehmen muss sich Qualifizierung
Fort- und Weiterbildung noch stärker
etablieren
und der zunehmende Druck der auf den
Schultern der Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern lastet ist enorm man muss
flexibler werden verfügbarer intensiver
arbeiten Arbeitszeiten und Privatleben
vermischen immer mehr ineinander und das
macht den Schutz aber auch die
Gesundheitsprävention zu einem immer
größeren und wichtigeren Thema und wenn
Ihnen liebe cdu/csu die Gesundheit der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer am
Herzen liegt dann würde ich mich
zumindest sehr freuen und ich glaube
auch viele Menschen draußen die hart
arbeiten wenn sie aufhören würden
ständig von Flexibilisierung untergraben
des Arbeitsschutzes zu sprechen indem
sie an der Schraube der
Höchstarbeitszeiten drehen wollen das
ist sicher kein richtiger Schritt um
Fachkräfte zu gewinnen das ist nicht
nachhaltig und damit tun sie auch den
Arbeitnehmern keinen Gefallen mit der
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
werden wir den Fachkräftemangel gezielt
angehen stehen sehr gute Punkte drin
beispielsweise die bessere Koordination
der Weiterbildungsangebote zwischen Bund
und Land steht bei ihnen auch drin
Entwicklungschancen im gesamten
Lebensverlauf fördern bessere
Ausstattung der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
wieder Richtung einer
weiterbildungsplattform und ein
qualifizierungsgeld für Achtung
Unternehmen das müsste sie an dieser
Stelle ja auch freuen Ihre Forderung
sehe ich damit weitestgehend als erfüllt
im Grunde genommen als übererfüllt an
und ein Thema ist mir auch noch ganz
besonders wichtig meine Kollegin Rascha
nasse hat das auch schon angesprochen um
den Fachkräftemangel zu bewältigen
können wir das nicht nur mit
inlandspotenzialen wir brauchen auch
Einwanderung und mit der
einwanderungsstrategie der
Bundesregierung werden wir zur Abmeldung
des Fachkräftemangels erheblich
beitragen Menschen die hier leben und
arbeiten wollen brauchen eine
Perspektive die muss transparent und
zügig erfolgen und diese Menschen müssen
dauerhaft in Deutschland bleiben können
und dafür
und dafür müssen wir das einwanderungs
das Aufenthalts aber auch das
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht aus meiner
Sicht dringend modernisieren und
Bürokratie einmal gestalten trinkt
benötigte Fachkräfte fallen schließlich
nicht vom Himmel wir freuen uns über
jeden der zu uns nach Deutschland kommt
ich finde Ihren Antrag zugegebenermaßen
nicht ganz so schlecht ich glaube das
ist auch durchgeklungen da sind ein paar
gute Punkte drin die in der
fachkräftestrategie ja auch sozusagen
aufgehen dementsprechend auf gute Arbeit
in den Ausschüssen freue mich und ihnen
später ein schönes Wochenende
na das ist doch auch mal ganz erfreulich
wenn man sich untereinander lobt klingt
doch gleich viel schöner an einem
Freitag ohne ihn sondern Bayram jetzt
für die mindestgrünen sie ist die Opfer
im rechtsaus
Schuss vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe
diesen Antrag der Union gelesen und habe
dann wirklich die Frage ist das ein
Antrag oder kann das weg denn sie haben
dort Forderungen von uns abgeschrieben
braucht das nee wir haben es auch
aufgeschrieben jeder hat es transparent
nachgelesen steht da was neues drin nach
16 Jahren könnte man ja meinen sie sind
mal in sich gegangen und haben
festgestellt was sie falsch oder nicht
gemacht haben und das Schreiben sie
jetzt in diesen Antrag weil sie denken
wir geben unsere Erfahrungen weiter an
eine Regierung die daraus was macht nö
keine Einsicht hinsichtlich ihrer
Versäumnisse auch das steht in dem
Antrag leider nicht drin auch insoweit
kann der Weg ja und drittens was fehlt
da drin eigentlich es fehlt das
Potenzial der Menschen im Inland die
schon da sind und die eben
einen Status haben indem sie wechseln
wollen vom Status Menschen der hier aus
einer Not aus einer Flucht
herausgekommen ist und der Teil unserer
Gesellschaft werden will und sich hier
einbringen will der kommt in ihrem
Antrag überhaupt nicht vor und deswegen
mein Resümee dieser Antrag kann weg und
wir werden ihn auch sofort wegstimmen
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
die Beiträge die Beiträge aus der Union
werfen wir eine Frage auf die wirklich
gefährlich ist und ich frag mich auch
warum eigentlich Frau Lindholz heute in
dieser Debatte nicht da ist die sonst in
einer Art und Weise über geflüchtete und
Migranten redet bei der es mir schlecht
wird und da verstellt sich halt wirklich
die Frage meine Damen und Herren von der
Union wollen Sie wirklich das
Deutschland so unattraktiv und schlecht
ist das ist eigentlich nur die AFD
stärkt bitte gehen Sie in sich er liegen
sie nicht der Gefahr dieses Land auf
eine Art und Weise zu gestalten dass wir
unattraktiv werden für Menschen aus dem
Ausland die wir hierhin holen wollen und
für Menschen die schon da sind denen wir
einen Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht geben
wollen meine Damen und Herren
und ich hoffe und das werden weitere
Debatten hier zeigen dass sie der Gefahr
nicht erliegen und dass die
Entschuldigung ihres
Fraktionsvorsitzenden ernst gemeint war
dass sie nicht die Gruppen gegeneinander
ausspielen denn andernfalls kann man
Ihren Antrag auch nicht verstehen warum
da einerseits steht die Menschen sollen
mehr arbeiten andererseits sagen sie die
Frauen sollen auch mehr arbeiten
gleichzeitig kommen die MigrantInnen gar
nicht vor ihr Antrag ist nicht zu Ende
gedacht aber wir reden natürlich gerne
mit Ihnen über unsere Lösungsangebote
und es folgt für die FDP-Fraktion
Friedhelm boginski
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der cdu/csu
es irritiert mich immer ein bisschen
also ich möchte eigentlich nicht diese
16 Jahre ständig vorwerfen aber wenn
jemand 16 Jahre Verantwortung gehabt hat
und dann solche Anträge stellt muss er
sich nicht wundern dass wir darauf immer
wieder zurückkommen denn das hat ja so
ein bisschen das Gefühl wie jemand der
nicht Auto fahren kann und ständig
Unfälle baut und sich dann hinterher
hinstellt und sagt ich mache jetzt eine
Fahrschule auf oder ähnliches also da
habe ich schon ein bisschen Problem mit
wir haben
wir haben natürlich riesengroße Probleme
in Deutschland und dazu gehört ohne
Zweifel der Arbeitskräfte Mangel und es
wurde heute schon darauf hingewiesen 80
Milliarden gehen uns durch diese
Wirtschaftsleistung verloren und wir
sind als Ampel auch auf dem Weg und
versuchen Deutschland für die Zukunft
fit zu machen und dazu gehören für uns
drei Säulen das wissen sie auch das ist
einmal die duale Ausbildung
weiterentwickeln der massive Ausbau der
berufsorientierten Weiterbildung und die
fachkräftezuwanderung und wir haben das
klar erkannt und deshalb hat unsere
Ministerin Bettina stark Watzinger mit
den Kollegen heil und Harbeck auch eine
Pressekonferenz
durchgeführt und die
weiterbildungsstrategie noch mal
eindeutig
dargestellt an ihren Antrag fehlen mir
zwei Sachen durch die eine Sache ist
schon sehr intensiv hingewiesen worden
das heißt die Überschrift lautet ja
Fach- und Arbeitskräfte im Inland
gewinnen das heißt also sie blenden die
Möglichkeiten die wir euch Zuwanderung
von Fachkräften haben könnten vollkommen
aus wir brauchen pro Jahr 400.000 bis
750.000 Fachkräfte und die werden wir in
Deutschland alleinig gewinnen aber ich
will auf eine zweite Gruppe hinweisen
die mir besonders wichtig ist und wo ich
einfach mich wundere dass sie darauf bis
zum sprechen kommen wir haben in
Deutschland 6,2 Millionen Menschen die
gering literalisiert sind das heißt sie
können weder lesen noch schreiben und
die fallen ja nicht vom Himmel das sind
ja Menschen die sind heute im
erwerbsfähigen Alter das heißt sie sind
durch ein Bildungssystem gegangen dass
ihnen nicht lesen und Schreiben
beigebracht hat das noch mal zur
Erinnerung und ich finde diese Menschen
sind es wert dass wir uns um Sie kümmern
dass wir Ihnen Möglichkeiten bieten in
die Fachkräfte hineinzukommen sich hier
mit einzubringen die finden ja bei ihnen
überhaupt nicht statt und in der Alpha
Dekade sind wir noch mal auf dem Weg
dass die Faktor besser in den Griff zu
bekommen und wir werden als Ampel und
sehr intensiv für die Fachkräfte
Sicherung kümmern wir haben das auf den
Weg gebracht das ist für uns eines der
ganz priorien Ziel die wir haben und ich
denke da brauchen wir ihre Anträge hier
in den Sinne nicht danke schön
[Applaus]
letzter Redner in dieser Debatte ist kW
Mansouri für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin lieber Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren auf den
Zuschauerbänken und zu Hause ich fühle
mich ja geehrt dass jetzt zum Schluss
der Debatte auch meinetwegen der
Oppositionsführer gekommen ist leider
haben sie verpasst Herr Merz dass der
Erkenntnisgewinn ausgerechnet in ihrer
Fraktion in dieser Debatte gleich null
gewesen ist
sie haben eine Vielzahl von Punkten
aufgelistet die sie anbringen wollen um
den Fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen aber
wenn ich mir das mal in der Substanz
anschaue wenn es immer um das Thema
Bildungsgerechtigkeit geht dann höre ich
aus ihren Reihen sozialistische
Bevormundungen bei der
Ausbildungsgarantie sagen sie das
braucht keiner das Bürgergeld das
Qualifizierung und Fortbildung für
Menschen in der Erwerbslosigkeit stärken
soll um dauerhaft in Beschäftigung zu
kommen das verunglimpfen sie als
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen bei
Zuwanderung sagen sie immer pulleffekt
Brücken zu bauen für gut integrierte
Menschen in der Duldung ins
Aufenthaltsrecht da fällt ihnen immer
illegale Einwanderung ein Arbeitszeit
wollen sie deregulieren und den
Arbeitsschutz beschimpfen sie immer als
Bürokratie meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Fachkräfte fallen nicht vom Himmel dafür
muss man etwas tun und das können wir
ihrem Antrag nun wirklich nicht
entnehmen
und es wohnt mich wirklich wenn
ausgerechnet aus ihren Reihen das Thema
Bildungschancen und Schulabbrecherquote
thematisiert wird ich habe mal mit 16
angefangen mich politisch zu engagieren
in der Schülervertretung weil es mir
ungerechte Bildungschancen gegangen ist
und wenn wir uns mal die Situation in
den Schulen anschauen da hängt immer
noch der Bildungserfolg von Kindern
stärker vom Portemonnaie als von ihren
Talenten ab individuelle Förderung zu
stärken das wäre mal ein wirkliches
Instrument gegen Schulabbrecher
und wie ungerechtes in unserem
Bildungssystem zugeht das haben wir
glaube ich unter corona-bedingungen alle
eindrucksvoll gespürt da gäbe es viel zu
tun mit mehr Personal mit besseren lehr-
und Lernbedingungen es gebe darum in
einem so starken viland wie unsere mehr
in Bildung zu investieren und ehrlich
gesagt meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sagen Sie das
doch mal ihren Ministerpräsidenten ein
paar Stellen sie ja noch von der Union
und wenn es um das Thema Zuwanderung
geht
dann geht es darum Sprache und
Integration vom ersten Tag an zu stärken
es geht darum auch ein gesunden
Pragmatismus walten zu lassen für
Menschen die jahrelang hier leben die
gut integriert sind und für die wir
jetzt das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
auflegen wollen da geht es um bis zu
100.000 geduldete die auch eine große
Rolle in unserem Arbeitsmarkt spielen
könnten dafür muss dann anschließend
vieles passieren bei Anerkennung von
Abschlüssen etc und auch da sehen wir
keine Unterstützung auf ihrer Seite
und nicht zuletzt geht es darum dass wir
nicht nur dafür sorgen dass Menschen in
Arbeit kommen sondern dass sie auch
gesund und zufrieden und motiviert in
Arbeit bleiben können bis zur Rente und
das hat viel zu tun mit anständigen
Arbeitsbedingungen das hat viel zu tun
mit Prävention und Gesundheitsförderung
das hat viel zu tun damit dass
Arbeitszeiten eingehalten werden das
Ruhezeiten eingehalten werden das ist
Fortbildungen zum Arbeitsschutz gibt und
das vor allem auch das Thema der
mentalen Gesundheit endlich
enttabuisiert wird alles Punkte die Teil
auch unserer fachkräftestrategie sind
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
und vor allem geht es darum gerade in
denen Berufssparten die heute auch
angesprochen worden sind dafür zu sorgen
dass nicht immer mehr Druck die Menschen
krank macht und da müssen wir auch uns
die Personalschlüssel anschauen nicht
nur im Bereich der Pflege der heute
angesprochen worden ist sondern in
vielen anderen sozialen Berufen auch ich
will mal einen konkretes Beispiel
bringen das heute nicht angesprochen
wurde der Bereich der Kitas wo meine
Mutter und viele Erzieherinnen und
Erzieher in dieser Republik Arbeiten
einen Bereich der ein echter Knochenjob
ist wo Menschen gefordert werden wo man
eine hohe Qualifikation braucht und
keine Reichtümer verdient und da macht
es einen Unterschied dort man acht
Kinder betreut oder 15 lassen Sie uns
dafür bessere Arbeitsbedingungen sorgen
meine Damen und Herren
und das macht deutlich das Thema der
fachkräftebekämpfung das ist deutlich
komplizierter als hier 20 spiegelstriche
aufzuschreiben ich persönlich glaube
nicht an den Weihnachtsmann ich glaube
auch nicht daran dass es ihnen Ernstes
mit dem Thema der Fachkräfte Sicherung
aber wenn doch dann fühlen sie sich dazu
herzlich eingeladen sich konstruktiv
hier in die Diskussion einzubringen
herzlichen Dank
die Oppositionschef Friedrich Merz war
schon etwas länger da ist vor allen
Dingen auch deshalb bekommen weil er in
meinem nächsten debattenpunkt sprechen
wird doch zunächst hier die Abstimmung
über den Antrag der CO2 35 mit dem Titel
Fach und Arbeitskräfte mit
zielgerichteten Maßnahmen im Inland
gewinnen wer stimmt für den Antrag das
ist die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP wer enthält sich das ist
die afd-fraktion damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 27
a bis 27c Beratung der Unterrichtungen
durch die Bundesregierung über den
Bericht des Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland 2022
sowie über den Jahresbericht der
Bundesregierung zum Stand der deutschen
Einheit 2021 und wir beraten auch den
Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem
Titel 32 Jahre deutsche Einheit
Schutzschirm gegen Inflation und
armutspannen Lohn- und renteneinheit
herstellen für die Aussprache ist eine
Dauer von 39
ein neuer Blick wurde Ende September von
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für
Ostdeutschland Carsten Schneider
vorgestellt dieses Format soll sich
künftig in jeweils zweijährigen Rhythmus
mit dem traditionellen Bericht zum Stand
der deutschen Einheit abwechseln und
Carsten Schneider Staatsminister im
Kanzleramt Beauftragter der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland fängt
an vielen aufsetzen dieses
Jahresberichts der heutigen Debatte hier
im Freitag im Bundestag wir hatten am
dritten am 3 oktober in Erfurt die
Feierlichkeiten danke auch sehr der
Bundestagspräsidentin für ihre Rede dort
und ich habe eine Veränderung
vorgenommen
es findet für 2022 nicht der übliche
Jahresbericht zum Stand der deutschen
Einheit statt sondern wollte ein Bericht
zum Auftakt der Legislatur machen der
den Blick ein wenig weitert und auch
erweitert und auch die Zivilgesellschaft
einbindet im nächsten Jahr wird es den
üblichen Jahresbericht auch wieder geben
den wir für 22 hier diskutieren dazu
habe ich 16 Gastautoren eingeladen
Autorin Autoren aus unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftlichen Hintergründen aus
unterschiedlichen Regionen die kritisch
über den derzeitigen Stand aber
insbesondere auch über die große Chance
und Potenziale Ostdeutschlands schreiben
die Beiträge die zeigen die
umsetzungsschwierigkeit aber auch die
Herausforderung auch die Freiheit in die
in Ostdeutschland sich bahngebrochen hat
und dieses Land geprägt hat und auch
Deutschland insgesamt stärker gemacht
hat
es ist in der vergangenen Jahren eine
neue eigene Energie und Dynamik
entstanden und vor allen Dingen auch an
neues Selbstbewusstsein ich lege den
Bericht den Wert Schwerpunkt ist bei uns
auf die gestaltungsschancen und auf die
vielen aktiven Bürgerinnen und Bürger
vor Ort die sich für die Gesellschaft
und für die Demokratie einsetzen
der Titel lautet ein neuer Blick denn zu
lange standen die Defizite
Ostdeutschland im Mittelpunkt der
öffentlichen Debatte der
Vergleichsmaßstab war stets der Westen
zu dem der Osten aufschließen sollt ein
neuer Blick das bedeutet auch zur
Kenntnis zu nehmen das ostdeutsche
Besonderheiten nicht einfach irgendwann
verschwinden werden sie fordern und
bereichern unser Land das heutige
Deutschland ist kein Westdeutschland
plus sondern ein neues vielfältiges Land
inmitten Europas
war es übrigens auch ich sag mal bei
vielen Soli Debatten in vergangen 30
Jahren gehabt der natürlich auch im
Osten gezahlt wurde Westdeutschland wäre
auch allein ein ärmeres Land heute als
Ostdeutschland
und das nicht nur ökonomisch oder
kulturell und ich glaube auch menschlich
die die gute Entwicklung Ostdeutschlands
belegen auch die vielen
Unternehmensansiedlungen der jüngsten
Zeit ich war es am Montag in Magdeburg
habe mit Vertretern des Chip-Herstellers
Intel gesprochen der dort investiert
begleitet und unterstützt durch die
Bundesregierung und auch die
Landesregierung tausende Arbeitsplätze
im Bereich der Halbleiterindustrie
werden dort entstehen
ein neuer Blick das heißt jedoch nicht
die Probleme zu verschweigen im
Gegenteil die Herausforderung des Ostens
und auch Unzufriedenheiten werden offen
benannt und sie stehen auf der Agenda
dieser Bundesregierung oben
zum Beispiel die niedrigen Einkommen
zum Glück eine Bundestag beschlossen das
zum ersten Oktober vielen Dank dafür
auch noch für die Mehrheit die das
mitgetragen hat den Mindestlohn auf 12
Euro zu erhöhen das bedeutet für über
eine Million Menschen höherer Einkommen
allein der Landkreis Sonneberg im
schönen Thüringen 44 Prozent der
Beschäftigte
sozialversicherungspflichtig
beschäftigen dort verdienen unterhalb
von 12 Euro das heißt 44 Prozent der
ihre Menschen haben von dieser
mindestlohnerhöhung profitiert dass das
Mindeste was wir geben können der Rest
müssen ja Tarif die Tarifparteien
bewerkstelligen dafür haben sie auch die
volle Unterstützung für mehr
Tarifbindung und auch gewerkschaftliche
Organisierung und auch die der
Unternehmen in ihren Verbänden durch die
Bundesregierung auf die Bundeskanzler
oder nehmen wir zogen auf die Defizite
die Tatsache dass die Ostdeutschen zwar
17 Prozent der Bevölkerung ausmachen
aber nur 3,5 Prozent der
Führungspositionen
da läuft etwas schief in Deutschland und
zwar in allen Bereichen
deshalb arbeiten wir ans Bundesregierung
und meinem Staat bei einem Konzept für
den Bund die Vielfalt unserer
Gesellschaft nicht nur auf ostdeutsche
bezogen sondern insgesamt auch für Leute
mit Migrationshintergrund diese zu
erhöhen und diese Repräsentanz Lücke die
es gibt die vieler für die Akzeptanz von
demokratischen Entscheidungen mit sich
bringt zu verändern und auch mehr
ostdeutsche insbesondere auch Frauen in
Führungspositionen zu halten
liebe Kolleginnen
vielen Dank für die Unterstützung in den
vergangenen neun Monaten vielen Dank
insbesondere auch für die Unterstützung
für das zukunftszentrum und die
Entscheidung die wir insbesondere auch
für die Unterstützung der Chemie und der
raffineriestandorte treffen konnten
herzlichen
folgt für die cdu/c
su Friedrich Merz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren es ist eine
interessante Abweichung von der
bisherigen Übung nicht nur den Bericht
der Bundesregierung zum Stand der
deutschen Einheit einmal im Jahr zu
diskutieren sondern heute auch einen
Bericht des Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für Ostdeutschland und
dies mit einem anderen Blick wie sie
sagen Herr Schneider zu versehen
entscheidend wird sein dass wir auch in
Zukunft regelmäßig Gelegenheit haben uns
mit den besonderen Herausforderungen des
Ostens unseres Landes zu beschäftigen es
darf nicht zur pflichtgemäßen Routine
werden sondern muss ein wichtiger
Gegenstand unserer Beratungen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag bleiben
jenseits der Berechtigten
wirtschaftlichen Anliegen der
Bevölkerung in diesem Teil unseres
Landes müssen wir vor allem über die
deutlich abnehmende Zustimmung zu
Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft sprechen
dies ist für ganz Deutschland
besorgniserregend und für den Osten ganz
besonders ich möchte aus meiner Sicht
drei Argumente oder drei Vorschläge
unterbreiten wie wir dem begegnen können
zum einen wir dürfen nicht nur reden wir
müssen zuhören und das haben sie mit
ihrem Bericht und auch den Autoren die
sie dort haben zu Wort kommen lassen